He's saying, "You're a little [__] who won't criticize
me like overtly with a video cuz then I could respond. So, you
do these little snipes cuz you're a little bitch." I I I don't
know if I can watch this. What am I supposed to take this person
seriously? They can't just say what the problem is. They They
have to be homophobic and rude the whole time. 109 online community
is LonerBox as pulling out with for no fault of his own. What
a disgusting prick, man. Whenever I like talk about them, somebody's
watching the stream as I like mock their neuroticism constantly.
They're through tears just waiting for the moment where I talk
about LonerBox or the Discord so they can clip that and post
it in the Discord. I got you now. You said mean things about
me. You said mean things about the Discord. What the
You guys know who Spider is, right? We should cover this real
quick.
LonerBox clipper
editor for LonerBox like a second LonerBox channel. E He sent
this He tweeted this the other day.
And it's just funny. It says 37,000 views now.
It's very very very interesting this this tweet cuz it spiraled
into like Hasan replied to some tweets under this. LonerBox replied,
Queenman replied.
And I'll be honest, I thought I thought Spider was with LonerBox.
I thought Spider went and listened to Queenman and took the things
Queenman said and then basically reformulated it and asked LonerBox
to [__] with him. That's what I thought Spider was
doing here. I didn't think Spider was sincerely asking a question,
okay?
But it's very funny. Let's Let's just give it a quick read. I'm
honestly a bit LonerBox did say that people do this like a racist
What did he call it?
A bonics accent or something like that? When people do Spider
I don't do that. What the [__] Now I'm Now I'm like
torn. Should I try to do a Spider impression for this? I don't
know. I don't know if I should. AV, [snorts] yeah, that's right.
Okay. I'm honestly a bit confused about LonerBox at Box Loner's
position on the current situation with Iran. And maybe I'm misunderstanding
it. From what I've seen, it sounds like he thinks the operation
is bad because Donald Trump is in office, but I've also heard
that if Joe Biden were a president, he might take have a different
stance, which is why I'm confused. Would his view actually change
if the same type of operation happened under Biden? Or does he
think Biden would have handled it differently like going to Congress
first? I'm also skeptical about the idea that bombing Iran would
lead to regime change because if the US bombed Iran for months,
I don't think the Iranian population would suddenly become
It would probably just increase anti-American sentiment.
It also sometimes feels like the US is by Israel into a conflict
with Iran. And if someone says that pointing this out automatically
makes you anti-Semitic, I think that's a weak argument. Criticizing
US foreign policy or Israel's influence isn't the same thing
as anti-Semitism. And sometimes accusations of anti-Semitism
seem to get used as a shield by people bringing up grandparents
their grandparents' traumatic experiences
from past generations to shut down criticism
instead of actually addressing the argument. Ooh, a Holocaust
industry argument from Spider.
You love to see
Did this guy read Norm Finkelstein's seminal work The Holocaust
Industry?
Oh my goodness.
At Grok, summarize this post into a couple of sentences.
It literally is a couple of sen- The [__] It literally
is a couple of sentences. What are we doing here?
That's literally a couple of sentences.
The [__] Okay, and then Missy This is Missy Elliott
in the chat. If you guys know Missy, I think Missy's a mod.
Missy Elliott says, "One of LonerBox's important community members
has similar questions to Queenman's about his position on Iran.
Chud Logic offer Chud Logic's offer to moderate a conversation
seems like a great opportunity to clarify. Make it happen, boys."
And then Missy links this. And somehow
somehow some way Hasan [__] finds his way into these
replies. I have no idea how this happened. What did Hasan say?
"They're gaining sentience." The LonerBox mods community members.
"I welcome developments."
I Does he mean I welcome development? I welcome developments.
I don't know what's going on here, okay? Okay. Uh I'm being totally
sincere. This is healthy intellectual curiosity.
Some context for the disagreement. This is the the Queenman stuff.
This is Queenman's like um anger with LonerBox, right? I thought
Spider was taking Queenman's questions and asking them intentionally
to [__] with LonerBox. I thought he was like poking
him. Like, "Ah, these are questions." Right? These are questions
you should answer.
But I I think Spider just, you know,
accidentally asked the same questions. So, we'll see when when
Queenman says what I believe to be roughly the same
We'll see if there's actually a difference, okay? I'm going to
hit play on this. We'll check it out. At some point, there does
kind of need to be a change. So, it's just a very real shame
that you've got Trump and Hegseth leading the charge right now.
>> Like for this to be your complaint, you have to be a
This is like the most zogged out complaint in the world. This
is like Very mean. Very zogged out. Very mean. >> like
Oh, the problem with Israel is Netanyahu. It's like that level
of f This is what I think about all the time. The problem is
not
Hegseth and Trump.
The problem I It feels so crazy to say the Netanyahu thing. The
problem isn't
The problem is Israelis. I'm sorry to say. The problem is Israelis
and what they've where they've ended up as a society, okay? Culturally,
their their cultural zeitgeists. That's the problem. I'm sorry.
Now, it's not genetic or anything, okay? I'm not making that
claim. I'm just saying the problem is who they vote for, how
they vote. The problem is the constitution of the country, okay?
Problem is the actions. It doesn't matter if Biden did this,
it would still be illegal, deranged,
Now, I'm assuming Here's what I'm actually assuming.
LonerBox doesn't actually think that. LonerBox doesn't actually
think, "Oh, the problem is Hegseth and
What LonerBox actually means is the problem is the whole attack.
The whole thing has been bungled in a terrible way because it's
done by Trump and Hegseth. Because they're idiots, they've done
it this way. But he still wants to defend the act. That's the
issue. That's why he's doing it this way. This is ultimately
what it comes down to
I think Queenman thinks it's wrong to go after Iran in this situation
given Iran's actions up to this point, especially as like commander-in-chief
of the US forces.
Right? And LonerBox does think it's okay to go after Iran.
I I think I had this argument in his Discord a little bit. But
in my opinion, Iran is And And this will trigger people. But
Iran's never going to act in a way that actually makes it so
the US has to do something to them. Like this all The only thing
that happened here is the United States is led by a once-in-a-generation
that got convinced to go in and do this.
Iran, while very very bad, is never going to [__]
with US interests in a way where the US has to go and [__]
with them, right?
And it it just It takes a a mountain, a heap of gaslighting to
convince anybody of anything else. Iran is explicitly And they
will [__] with things. They'll go and hit people.
They'll go and hit proxies. They'll go even go and hit US bases
sometimes. But they're not going to do anything that would actually
force the US to hit them back. Right?
Can't pretend pretend to care about international law and support
the attack? Yeah, probably not. Most people don't really care
about international law, it seems. But even if he built a coalition
and had like all of NATO and like UN approval to go into Iran,
I
it's still probably not a good calculation on on the US like
on the United States' part. I just don't think they're economically
where they need to be to go and try to project power into the
Middle East to do regime change for other people.
I I I just disagree that that's a thing they should be undertaking
at this point in the country's life cycle, right? I think they
need to s- They need to take all their money and put it to domestic
manufacturing, okay?
So that they don't have So, they're not beholden to Iran and
China in this exact way that they are right now. So, they're
not grabbed by the balls, scared to upset the global economy,
okay?
That's what they need to do. That's why he's making this argument.
He wants to defend the strike.
He wants to say, "Yes, Israel securing its interests is good
actually."
That's what he wants people to think. So, he does it like this.
He goes, "Well, the problem is Trump and Hegseth." But then no,
that maybe there is a chance There is genuinely a chance. And
I have I've seen flashes of this in in LonerBox. I've seen flashes
of this truly subhuman mindset from LonerBox where he's all like,
"Woo woo, who cares about That's really mean. Why is What's wrong
with this guy? Why is this guy Why can't he just make like good
criticisms? Why does he have to be like a jerk to everybody?
Does anyone know? Like this guy's like woke up on the wrong side
of the bed this
He's just like making fun He like even knows that probably LonerBox
didn't mean that, but then he's just going to be like, "This
guy is subhuman." And then he does like a voice for him. He does
like a Hila Klein voice for him. That's brutal, man. What are
you implying about him cognitively to do the Hila Klein voice
as if that's him? from LonerBox where he's all like, "Woo woo,
who cares about international law? Who cares if we're doing negotiations?
We strike them anyway." He was saying this stupid [__]
about what was it? The Qatari strike?
So, that it may be that LonerBox has this like subhuman mindset
of [__] international law, you know, just let America
exercise its influence. He may He He may truly, you know, lean
towards that now. I think liberal fascism is the best term for
it. They're are just these zogged liberal fascists
like LonerBox and Destiny. But I don't The thing is is I think
they opposed the Venezuela thing when if this is going to be
your attitude like America first, we just we get to do what we
want cuz we're strong, nobody cares about international law anyway,
we're going to secure our interests, then how are you against
the Venezuela stuff the Venezuela stuff? Even the striking of
the boats.
You have to be for those things if you're for the Iran strikes,
right? But for LunarBox
and uh how do I put this? I I probably have to come up with a
better way of saying it, so it's not like so egregious.
Like I'm sure he he has reasons he supports Israel, he has reasons
he thinks Iran is evil. I don't really know his reasons, I haven't
watched a lot of his content recently, but he has reasons he
thinks that. But ultimately it comes down to I need people to
understand that I think Iran is a massive deal and they have
to be displaced. Like the Iranian regime is a massive deal. Right?
That's why he supports it because he's signaling that the Iranian
regime is very very very bad.
That's why he has to support this. And I
Yeah, I I don't know how you do the dance there. I really don't
know how you do the dance. Cuz if international law is important,
then you hate the Venezuela stuff, you probably hate the Iran
stuff. If it's America first, then you you definitely like the
Venezuela stuff. And depending on what level of zog you are,
you hate or love the Iran
I don't know how you hate the Venezuela stuff and love the Iran
stuff. That's a combination that doesn't make sense to
Outside of
>> just being a zogful fellow, okay?
And I don't Listen.
Just in case LunarBox watches this, I'm not saying like he's
incapable of changing his mind or he's like owned by Israel or
something. I don't think that. I just think he has a lot of like
that
perspective around him of like people in Israel. And I think
he
is consistently
like letting people know he understands how they feel. But I
Ultimately, I disagree.
I don't think there's really any way to defend the Iran strikes
in my opinion. who basically think that yeah, might does make
right. That is essentially their mentality. They don't really
believe in international law. They don't really believe you have
to follow the process.
They don't really believe there should be a process. They they
do really kind of think that and they do kind of lean that way
and you I've seen that I have seen that from LunarBox.
So, we've got a LunarBox response to this. Our dear friend
friend of the show LoserBox
he was uh close to talking to me, I think. But then he's like
I need I need a good I need a good faith critique first. So,
he must look at at something here first and then maybe he goes
back to it, I think. I think. Or is it earlier? It's earlier.
This is the second part. So, yeah, LoserBox is doing this gay
ish where he's like you're being bad faith. It's like not his
name.
This guy is such a dick, man. What the
Has he ever heard of like if you don't have anything to say,
maybe don't say anything at all? Did his parents not teach him
this? If you don't have anything nice to say Mr. Quigman maybe
just don't say anything at all. Maybe keep it to
faith. You're being bad faith. It's like so just queer. I just
can't take it.
Oh, and the homophobia now. >> it. Uh-huh. >> got
to talk about it. We got to go over Uh-huh. Uh what do I want
to say to open this segment? What do I want What do I want to
talk about? I feel like I should lay some stuff out first. I
feel like I should um talk about my opinion on the Iran thing.
Cuz that's relevant here. But so this this disagreement, guys
I'm going to speak this out. Hold on. is over LunarBox's appearance
on
H3 podcast, mainly, okay? Oh, why is Lunar doing people happy
emotes? I don't know what that means. Well, I do know what that
means actually, precisely. I know what that means, but
I I think he's stretching. He's tired. He's EP. He's yawning,
okay? He's yawning and stretching. That's what he's doing. He
went on there and Ethan is obviously like pro the strikes,
He's like uh doing everything but saying this is awesome and
I support it. And the only hesitation that's like discussed,
really
is that it's Trump and Hexeth doing it. Now, there are some sort
of flashes of other considerations coming through from LunarBox,
but certainly not from Ethan. And he said LunarBox says at one
point
I Hey, I Before you even complain, Jimbly, I'd already flipped
that around.
It's that there's some formulation of the idea of intervening
in Iran that he would support.
But just nothing like this.
But at no point is he actually laying
what those conditions would be. And he's not really got a whole
lot of energy for the criticism of this action. Because fundamentally,
he does kind of just agree with it. Uh so, I guess you I'll talk
about when I would think it would be it would be justified.
Uh obviously, the biggest issues
the strikes right now, uh there was no imminent threat
to Israel or the United States, so there's no reason for them
to strike, just like in self-defense
They have not pursued
a UN Security Council resolution approving use of force.
the United States have not uh Congress has not approved it. So,
none of the democratic process or international process has been
followed. And that there's no there's no imminent threat. Now,
there are cases where that's that's not quite those criteria
are not quite fulfilled. And we still support intervention. The
one everyone brings up, obviously, is Kosovo.
Because there was not actually a UN Security Council resolution
authorizing use of force.
Wait, I'm trying to think cuz the UN definitely sent forces to
Kosovo.
Was it that the US intervened before the UN had done anything?
Cuz I'm almost positive the the UN sent Was it just NATO? I thought
it was UN peacekeeping forces were in Kosovo sweeping for mines.
Am I am I not remembering that correctly?
Who means about to explain? Okay. Cuz like I literally had a
family member who went to Kosovo to sweep for mines. And I could
have sworn he's told me that it was like via the UN. So, I would
be very confused. >> before the intervention in Kosovo,
making it technically illegal. However that was after the intervention
was still after like a year
of other resolutions through the UN and Security Council condemning
the violence, calling for an end, ordering them to stop. Bringing
uh there were like peace these huge peace talks between
um Russia the what what was called the contact group, which is
like Russia, the UK, US, France, I think someone else, that spoke
that did negotiations between the the Kosovo Liberation Army
or whatever the [__] it's called and um and the Yugoslavs.
And basically, the KLA
signed up to this deal that would have a NATO peacekeeping forces
in the area to stop everything and the and the the Yugoslavs
wouldn't. So, basically, it got to the point where the only way
they could intervene would be with a Security Council resolution
and Russia and China were like to veto it. So, we just have to
watch. And it's like yes, that's illegal. But the phrase was
illegal but legitimate. Because every other option had been exhausted
and it's just by any metric, any moral analysis, absolute action
had to be taken. That's not the case here. That's not the case
here. It just simply There has been like almost no attempt. There
have been these like show negotiations recently. The sad thing
is like with the Iran thing like you the case wasn't even made
to the American people. Like you would want at least your country
on your side, right?
Well, the US was clearly negotiating bad faith. And I mean, there's
just so many other considerations in Kosovo.
Like you're not going to [__] up anything else. You
There's no chance if you Trust me.
You could nuke Kosovo. World economy? Going to keep humming along,
okay? That's That's me doing anything for the world economy.
You nuke one of these countries in the Persian Gulf, we're all
I believe I could be wrong on this. J Soc told me this, so if
this is wrong, it's his fault. My understanding is they basically
wanted Iran to not even have like civilian nuclear enrichment
like nuclear enrichment for for uh power.
No, I didn't tell him that. That's Why would he say that and
then blame it on me? That's never been my understanding cuz that's
a real understanding. They literally offered to give them civilian
enrichment. They said, "We'll provide the uranium."
I I don't know why he just put that on me. That's totally made
up. I have no [__] I've never even thought that.
I've never even come close to thinking that. That's the problem.
This guy was listening to me at 4:00 a.m. playing some video
game, not listening to what I was actually saying, and just made
some [__] up on his stream. Pew. 7 days ago. >> They
actually get the power from the nuclear stations from America
to be totally dependent.
Okay, yeah, sure sure sure sure sure. No, it No, no, no. He said
it
like basically, you're not going to do civilian enrichment. No,
no, no, sorry, this is true. Never mind. I misunderstood him,
I guess.
No, that is true. That is what That is literally what the US
was >> Even further than the the JCPOA went.
Like it's totally crazy.
Like we cough and Kushner were So, if that's the case, I don't
have to do anything right now. I'll check that in a sec. I I'm
not going to do it right now. But the message you're giving over
is like, you know, there's basically giving over your country
really if you're just like saying yeah, I'm going to be energy
reliant on the US. That's like giving them handouts. So, yeah,
it's totally crazy. So, so all options are not being exhausted.
That's what I'm totally upset about. So, any So, here's my issue,
right? When LunarBox says
I would support this.
I would probably support as whatever he said. I would probably
support this if it weren't Trump and Hexeth. It's like yeah,
can I imagine a version of Iran intervention that I support?
Yes, I can imagine a version of Iran intervention I support.
But to say you would support this from anyone else, there's like
almost no aspect of this that I support, right? So, only in the
sense that there is some world in which Iran intervention is
justified and a good idea.
Where the timeline proceeding and the plan following are like
absolutely 100% different to how they are in reality. Yes, and
maybe I would I would support it. But then you're sort of not
really saying anything. Then you're really kind of just not [__]
doing anything. You're just saying you really don't like the
guy or anything they've done bad [__] recently that
should be stopped. And it's like yeah, fair fair enough. Slaughtering
tens of thousands of protesters is pretty [__] bad.
But that's unfortunately I I've said why I believe that is happening,
okay? It's literally the audience capture thing. Like he has
to He literally has to do this because his
If he implies that Iran is not like a great evil, he has to deal
with so much kvetching, okay? It would be You would You would
make the same bargain that Lonerbox has made, okay?
Trust me. If you were surrounded by the same people, you would
make the same bargain. Easily. But they didn't go and stop that
today. They didn't let that happen. They said, "Iranian people
rise up." And then gave the regime a month and a half to slaughter
them, systematically track them down and slaughter them. Yeah,
exactly. Orange bar becomes factor. So, all Lonerbox is saying
is that he he supports intervention as a concept. It's so worthless.
So, what the [__] are you actually saying? He's saying
Iran is bad.
Iran's actually bad. A lot of people say you shouldn't go there
cuz they like they don't know how bad Iran is, but Iran is really
bad. Iran's like really bad. Like really bad. Like really really
really bad. Really bad. So, let's see. Maybe Lonerbox lays out
his opinion more clearly. I don't have a good faith critique.
And then good faith critique than Lonerbox wants. By the way,
I
I don't watch that much Lonerbox content. This is like I'm This
is from interacting. This is my understanding, okay? It's not
based on like a whole bunch of, you know, study of his VODs.
Okay. Still think it's still think it's [__] correct,
though. I might as well do this slop. I mean, that's Quiment,
friend of the show. Used to rate him quite a bit. Had some talks.
Not particularly interesting, kind of restrained. What do you
call
What do you mean by saying it's not interesting? I'll have a
pretty interesting when you were calling Ethan a Zionist despite
the fact there's been a multi-year long drama that you stuck
your dick up off the entire time that's totally built on the
fact that people are quote unquote unfairly calling him a I thought
that was quite an interesting conversation, personally. I thought
it was an interesting conversation when you said it was anti-Semitic
to be against Israel as an ethno-state.
I thought it was quite an interesting But I'm sure those are
I'm sure just saying those things alone is enough for it to be
a bad faith critique even though those things literally happened
exactly how I said they did. Arm broken. I haven't seen it, so
I don't know. I just don't think they're arm broken.
I don't know. Someone sent me this. I probably watched a bit
of it. It's not the first time I've seen him kind of doing little
segments on me or often It's quite often segments that don't
go on to his actual channel segments. They just stay in the stream
by and nobody else sees it. Is Quiment What do we think here,
guys? Is Quiment going to get pissed at this that Lonerbox is
calling him a [__] outright? Or is Quiment just going
to say, "Oh, if you don't like it, we should talk." I feel like
it's the latter, but we'll see. I didn't really like I I I I
know the kind of irony he engages in when he does this. I just
don't really think it's worth covering, but I thought in the
current context it might be Do you have a chat replay here? I'll
be fine. I don't know what this guy's trying to say. This is
the thing, man. This is one of my pet peeves of Lonerbox. Oh,
you don't know what he's It's pretty obvious what he's trying
to say here. He's saying you're a little [__] who
won't criticize me like overtly with a video cuz then I could
respond. So, he does these little snipes cuz you're a little
[__] That's what he's saying.
Which is pretty clearly funny cuz, you know,
Quiment will talk to people. It's just This guy's got like the
same victim mindset as Destiny, where he thinks like everyone's
out to get him. It's just the way he's saying that.
So, is this like stream segments that like don't end up in on
the main channel? Like no one's hiding them, bro. So, why the
[__] do I upload it? I have a second channel where
I do dry actual politics stuff. Usually doing a proper segment
with my camera and [__] And I have my main channel
where I do drama slop [__] Lonerbox coverage doesn't
fit neatly into either.
So, it doesn't get uploaded. And usually it's not a full segment,
either. And you see this with him many times. Like he had a whole
thing where he was like cracking down on Discord splinter servers.
He's like, "I've got to I've got to do my my little long knives
on my mod team and get rid of the get rid of the snocker splinter
Discord servers." And it's I do I do want to actually know what
happened there.
Cuz I I ended up just giving up on this and cuz I had this like
happening where like people in my Discord were all and they they
like It's I I get how it's like a little
It is a little annoying cuz it feels like, you know, if you have
people who are in your audience who are like going to hang out
with other people who don't like you, it feels like they're going
to be convinced away from watching you or supporting you in some
way. I think what you need to make peace with is just the fact
that those people are already gone. That's what I That's what
I did and I've never been happier. All the Discord people, those
people already gone. They're all gone. I don't care about them.
As soon as I stopped caring about them, every every bit of my
like
content creation enjoyment just was totally fulfilled. I I was
just the weight off, right? You worry about it's like, "Oh, this
is the community I'm trying to build." It's like, "Oh, no, it's
not." Those people barely even watch.
No, those people barely watch at all.
Just focus on the people who actually come and watch and it's
all good. It's just like it is the taking it way too deep. I
see from sadly so many people. Let's see. Let's see what he has
to say about
Friends of Lonerbox. You can let me You can tell me if you think
this guy's like
a good faith critic or not, but it sounds like that's not necessarily
true when you use analysis. It's so crazy. I literally can't
take it. It makes me gag. It makes me gag hearing this F slash
A this [__]
Is he a good faith critic? Is he Is he a good faith critic? Yeah,
what about the homophobia? What do you mean by that? I'm saying
what I think. Okay. I get I don't know if I can watch this this
homo like What am I supposed to take this person seriously? They
can't just say what the problem is. They They have to be homophobic
and rude the whole
I feel like Could you imagine watching politics from somebody
who's like overtly caustic, homophobic sometimes, constantly
made references, was like just a completely
I don't know. Just a complete ass to everybody around them. Could
you imagine doing that? Like being friends with that person,
collabing with them. It'd be [__] insane. What a
disgusting prick, man. Do we keep I feel like I might just close
this. Wow. What does good faith and bad faith mean other than
you say what you think and don't lie about what the other person
thinks. That's what I'm doing. That's what I'm doing.
Do I say it in a mean way? Yes. Do I use personal attacks? Yes.
Is that bad
I wasn't aware it is. I I I I I was not aware of that. If that's
the case, I was not aware of it. My understanding was this was
an entertainment medium.
And if someone wanted to get dry, reliable political analysis,
they would read a [__] article. And then my job was
to present my thoughts, opinions, and information I've collected
in an entertaining way. Often times inflammatory to attract attention.
But the moment it's like There are people you can do this with.
Like me and Charles can do this no problem. Me and Jsou can do
this no problem. Then you get people like Lonerbox and Nick the
Oreo and it's like they've been harsh. They've been bad faith
to me. They've been bad faith to me. They've been toxic and bad
faith to It's a [__] livestream, dude. It's a [__]
It doesn't have to be the end of the world, bro. It doesn't destroy
the criticism that someone's making personal attacks against
me and it shouldn't.
It's a [__] But I don't want to Um oh. It doesn't
destroy the criticism. I do think I understand why it makes some
people not want to talk to you.
But ultimately,
ultimately I find
there's some element here where
there's something Destiny used to say that is true.
If the person who's talking [__] to you is like popular,
and they're they have like [__] criticism, then you
just win by engaging, right? Even if they're being an ass, you
win by engaging. So, if it's just bad faith critiques that you
can easily point out, then why wouldn't you want to go and talk
to them? Right? They'll be like, "Oh, come on, buddy. You know,
you don't need the internet, bro. I don't want to do this for
politics, but come on." What do Thank you for bringing this up.
They don't do banter in Scotland.
Everything on the whole. It doesn't have to be worse. It could
be. It could be worse in the sense that one outcome potentially
is the Ayatollah is gone, but then there's the youth of the IGC
who are [clears throat] easily the most indoctrinated. So, Lonerbox
has actually said For the Oh, you're being bad faith to me. You're
being bad faith to me. He's actually come in very late on this
segment, I
And I believe we're going to miss out the part of this here where
basically I that the point that's being made here is Lonerbox
is like entertaining the idea that there could be a good outcome,
I might have to go back and find it.
But Lonerbox is like, "Yeah, there could be good outcomes. There
could also be really bad ones." And he's laying out the bad one
here. But they've missed out the part where the whole intro into
this part of the conversation is talking about the idea of oh,
this could go well. And you're about to hear me basically say
there's no reason There is truly no reason to think this is going
to go well. To think this is going to suddenly get better. There
is no reason to believe Oh, I might have missed that, too. Yeah,
there's nothing. Dude, I I do feel like I would be totally Any
of the people I talked to early on about this conflict that disagreed
with me, I do feel like I was just 100% correct the entire time.
And anybody who wants to step into the Discord and and apologize,
I'm like okay with that. Anybody who wants to still stick with
any of the [__] they were saying, you want to talk
about the Shah? You want to talk about how this is going to go
well? How it could Bro, it's been a disaster. I The only criticism
you could have of me is possibly that on the first or second
night I didn't quite
say how big a disaster it would be. But I knew it was going to
be a disaster. I said it was going to be a disaster. I had all
the reasoning for it. And I still had people arguing like, "No,
no, you don't understand. They're terrorists." I Okay. You got
You're terrorizing my wallet, okay? My random random [__]
I have on Amazon subscribe and say subscribe and save is going
to go up 30% cuz you all suck. Cuz you're all cattle who will
clap along as Israel forces you to go and do this, okay?
[__] you.
So, let's see. The most radicalized faction of the entire Islamic
public. They're the youngest generation and they're more radical
and more hardline than I'm sorry, but it's all ready lost. I
don't think it's going to get better. And you're like Lonerbox
re-invites Destiny to his channel and Destiny uses Watching him
makes me feel like tripling my dose, ironically enough. [laughter]
So, I get the feeling Lonerbox is getting very passive upset.
And I am calling him a I'm not saying Ethan's a Ethan's doing
more of the But Lonerbox comes on and Lonerbox says,
"Yeah, it could it could go well. We might even pull the quote
unquote if this is if this is coming right." I haven't seen the
whole I haven't seen any of this. Lonerbox is raging, yeah. "Has
you Monarcus been arrested on suspicion for killing an anti-regime,
anti-Monarcus advocate, activist?" Nope, didn't see that. But
yeah, basically the point here is you're you sound like a If
you're entertaining entertaining the idea of like way heading
towards a free Iran. If you're seriously entertaining that possibility
right now, you sound I don't think that should be controversial.
Like this. Even just to me, it's like clearly what's happening.
It could be the situation changes.
But you have there is no evidence that that is going to be the
case. There is no reason. There's nothing being shown right now
that should lead you towards thinking that.
Trump is saying the Shah's not fit. It should be someone inside
the country. That's what Trump has said. They've also indicated
they might want someone from the existing regime. They said they
had guys they wanted to or are looking at taking over. Israel's
objectives obviously do not line up with Iran being like a free,
prosperous, democratic nation. They line up with Iran being a
Balkanized, ruined, failed state that can never hope to accumulate
the economic power to fund a nuclear program. So, there is nothing
you're we're looking at right now that indicates oh, this is
going to or a significant weapons program of any kind. Suddenly
better and result in a free
So to present it as a possibility to sit there and do the fan
fiction about it, the fair eyes and this is going to happen,
it does make you look
Open here. The US is already The US and Israel already destabilized
the country and the regime with the initial strikes on Fordow
and all that [__] earlier. Uh 6 months ago, whenever.
That already weakened the regime. There's been a swelling of
support for an opposition partly due to American and Israeli
interference and incitement.
US state officials from the Wait, wait, this is even a bad example
for me to use. Like the Pompeo [__] about the missiles
marching with that protesters. That's true, he did say that.
But Trump was out there tweeting and posting on Truth Social
like on January 13th or something like that. Rise up, Iranian
people. Rise up, rise up and take your country. Like they were
they were literally outright just they were inciting as if they
were going to help. And they say he's like saying like, oh yeah,
I don't don't kill the protesters. And they do nothing. They
do nothing. Stop it for weeks. Officials are saying say openly
It was a Huckabee, I think, or Pompeo, one of them said openly
good luck to all the Iranian protesters. And all of them are
Mossad agents. Sorry, I was I was about to wait for a drink.
Let's do 2 seconds. I'm just
Oh, sorry. Destiny 70 mean I think you're misunderstanding Kweiman's
When Kweiman says that he could envision an intervention that
could work, he doesn't mean this intervention as it started.
He means hypothetically, you could get your ducks in a row in
such a way that like Iranian regime change could work. It is
already categorically ruled out in this case. And he believes
Luna Box's analysis is that it's possible this current attack
will go well.
And he's That's the criticism. Is that it's stupid to say this
current attack could possibly go well.
Like there is just no indication whatsoever that this current
attack is going to be like effective in any way. Can I leave
this pause cuz I don't want to miss anything Luna says, okay?
So I just want a second. Yeah, I'm back. Marching alongside them.
They say this openly. They have fomented the resistance, the
opposition. >> How does that even work? So first of all,
I I don't know if he's forgotten, but you know Iran deals with
urban uprisings or protest uprisings like all the time. Like
every few years they're having to go through another round of
quelling and murdering protesters in the hundreds. Uh even before
the there was the hijab protest in 2022, I think um okay, before
that there was whatever one where they ended up massacring like
500 people there in 2009. Literally Commodore Trump, that is
an easy 30 minutes at least. When I literally said, I'm going
AFK for 1 minute.
It was one before that where they were trying to where they were
still trying to hold onto this idea of reformism, which has obviously
completely died now cuz the reformists have been in power for
a good while. At least in the presidency they haven't really
delivered. Um What what are we saying here? That the protesters
don't necessarily need a push from
Yep. My point is that when you push, which America and Israel
did, you in some way almost incur part of the responsibility,
you know? If you're going to go out there and say, come on, come
on, Iranian people. Rise up, rise up. Ayatollah, don't you dare
kill them. Don't you Oh, it's going to be real bad for you if
you kill them. And then you let them all die. You have incurred
some responsibility for that. That's the
For Did it How much of a push do you think Mossad are giving
them?
Not to say that the Iranian revolution Iranian opposition is
manufactured, fake. Not to say that they really think it and
Mossad have just come over and made a made a fake revolution.
No one's saying that. No one's saying that.
But the responsibility that the US and Israel incur for encouraging
behavior that benefited them led to the deaths of those people
and they did nothing about it. They have incited So I answer
That's just I don't know why he's pretending to understand like
the complexities of somewhere like Iran, but um That's just I
don't know why he's saying that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, wait. Pretend
Pretend to understand anything. Like can this guy do anything
without the [__] smarmy
Like he sounds like a leftist. Like do you read books? Do you
read books? It's like give the [__] rest, bro. Give
me the [__] rest. If I don't understand something,
then point out where the gap in my understanding is. But if you're
not contesting the conclusion or the argument in any reasonable
way, then it seems like I understand perfectly well enough to
make the claims I'm making.
Mm, he's contesting, isn't he?
My My understanding of Luna Box's response is
you're wrong in saying that this is incited even like There's
a There's a There's a completion happening. So Luna Box is going
to respond as if Kweiman's saying that this is mostly because
of incitement from the US and Israel, but I think Kweiman explicitly
said in
Which is sort of weaselly cuz it just means like is it 0.001%?
Well, that's still in part.
But so Luna Box is responding as if he's saying it's mostly because
of that. And he's saying I disagree with uh like obviously the
Iranian people have been protesting a lot. They don't like the
regime. That's been the case for a while. He sounds like a leftist.
Like do you read books? Do you read books? It's like give me
the [__] rest, bro. Give me the [__]
rest. If I don't understand something, then point out where the
gap in my understanding is. But if you're not contesting the
conclusion or the argument He literally did point out where the
gap in Kweiman's understanding is. I think it's a little bit
bit of a disingenuous response though, but Yeah. in any reasonable
way, then it seems like I understand perfectly well enough to
make the claims I'm making. I feel like mental to think that
there is not at least one outcome of this that could actually
be better for Iran. It's not like it would be the first ever
US intervention in a country where the regime is already insanely
unpopular that didn't result in something better. That's obviously
unstable now. But what What point is he making here? to think
that That's just I don't know why he's pretending to understand
like the complexities of somewhere like Iran, but um That's just
I don't know why he's saying that. Like is that like mental to
think that there is not
There's like
like technically aliens could come down and they could like
totally re-educate the Ayatollah and it would be like a you know
a solid liberal democracy.
Technically that could happen in the middle of this intervention
because of the intervention.
And right? Yeah, that could happen.
Of course that could happen. at least one outcome of this that
could actually be better for Iran. It's not like it would be
the first ever US intervention in a country where the Well, yeah,
Luna Box. No one's saying there's not a theoretically logically
possible outcome that could be better for Iran. Yes, Luna Box.
If I if I sit here Dr. Strange timeline analysis, yes, there
is at least one. There is at least one where it's better for
Iran. I would say I would say that, Luna Box, yeah. What a [__]
stupid vacuous point to make, seriously. What a [__]
stupid vacuous point to make.
Obviously what I'm saying is there is no
uh like reasonable evidence.
US and Israel were inciting people in part. evidence that would
reasonably lead you to the conclusion that it's going to be better
for Iran or it's likely to be better for Iran. That's a likely
outcome. That's a plausible outcome. You know, it may be logically
possible, but I don't see it as particularly plausible. Okay.
To borrow from Pisco. Yeah, I I just thought that's totally reasonable.
And Luna Box is like, oh, you really think there's no no world
where it could possibly No, I I see that it could
I just don't think that's going to happen. I think you sound
like a sitting there going, oh well, maybe there's one world
where this would actually turn out great. His uprising can still
win. regime is already insanely Yeah, it's like you sound like
you always sound doing this stuff. Make your analysis based on
what is reasonable, likely,
Not what's possible. Not what you think might be possible. It's
that same stupid YouTube idiot version doing on Destiny the other
night going like, oh yeah, but I What the [__] Think
it's it's possible that reasonable I think you should say it
would be a
popular that didn't result in something better. That's obviously
unstable now cuz there's still a war going on. Uh I think even
in the show, didn't they say that like I'm even saying here that
one of the outcomes is that the IRGC takes over and they are
worse. Yeah, unfortunately, Luna Box, you cut off the start of
the segment. You actually don't know what I'm saying here. So
that's unfortunate, Luna That's probably even That's probably
the most likely outcome. I have no idea what the is happening
with how many defectors they think they have or what the regular
army is going to do. But to suggest that like face critique from
Luna Box. I'm still listening to him though. can only uh get
worse. I I don't know what um You're a total paver if you say
this bad faith, by the way. Literally we're just shaming people
for this now. You're you're a total paver if you say this [__]
particular piece he's saying on that makes him so sure of
who were watching yesterday who said
Oh, Connor. Connor said this, okay? Connor said this. W counterpoints.
Saying the words bad faith is just a it's a like what do you
call it? Like a a flare, okay? Signaling flare to other that
you're a and you support them in your in your work, okay? You're
a You are trying to signal out. You're sending up a signal flare
to other
that No, no, no. No, I don't think he ripped the signal flare
thing. The thing
just something people have been saying for a long time.
But the um the signal flare thing I think was uniquely Connor,
no? Is that it? Okay. They have encouraged it. They have led
the Iranian people up to the precipice and then allowed tens
of thousands of them to be slaughtered at the hands of the Islamic
regime.
And then Remember, the protesters were already out en masse before
Trump said help is on the way. Help is on the The Trump thing
was disgusting. We talked about that a billion times, but that
he's He was still >> I'm not saying the whole protest was
Trump or the whole protest was Mossad. I'm saying that when you
encourage and incite, you incur some responsibility.
It's disgusting that you then go and leave those people to die.
So how upon
Yeah, sounds like Luna Box agrees. masse. They were still out
en masse. They were still They were still going to be that crackdown.
I Responding to a clip, Jim. Awful stuff. Well, he's not responding
to a clip, Jim. What's actually happened is he's been saving
over this while offline. He's pre-watched it and hasn't found
this start again cuz he was midway through it. Um and that's
why he's covering on stream because much like his Discord political
service, he can't stop thinking about it. I'm [__]
Look at that. They have alien Hopefully because Luna Box has
been hanging around a lot of Israelis.
We don't know for sure. Maybe they're all Arab Israelis, but
hopefully he's become you know, more accustomed to explicit and
obvious ham-fisted mind tricks, okay? He literally just said
that so that you will cover it, okay?
He's just trying to make it so that you can't not cover it, all
right? Now, that is just a very, very maneuver from Kweiman that
you need to identify immediately and put out of your mind, okay?
Don't take that seriously. They could have bombed all of that
leaving Take it seriously. with no plan for a
Leaving the country destabilized and rudderless. Lashing out
at other countries around them. Drawing attention, drawing aggro.
So you're blaming the Israel and the US for their recent killing
of their own. Um I mean, if I was a if I was being bad faith
or if I was jumping to conclusions or quite frankly not if I
was trying to avoid being looking for a better explanation, it
would sound like that, but I don't know. It's already worse.
It's already worse. I don't know why he's saying it's already
worse Well, because they murdered maybe over 10,000 of their
own people. I don't know what saying that's cuz that's not Like
Trump takes responsibility for emboldening protesters who were
already on the street. I don't know how Trump takes responsibility
for I don't know how Trump takes responsibility for the regime
killing them or for the protesters starting in the first place.
>> So you don't take responsibility for the regime killing
them, nor do you take responsibility for them starting.
You take responsibility for your actions, which is encouraging
them and promising help and then not delivering when they get
killed. That's what they have responsibility for. Hope that helps.
Hope that helps. I don't know why he's like I guess he's had
a severe head injury recently. Struggling with this one. But
yeah, you have responsibility for your actions.
This guy is so [__] lazy. He's just recycling the
kicked in the head by a horse talking point.
This is so This is so lazy, man.
What the [__] I don't know how This guy is recycling
He's just reusing an old script now, okay? He's got no time to
stream anymore. He's just reusing an old script. It works.
Already gotten tens of thousands of people killed. If you were
going to do this, act with a plan, Yeah. decisively, Yeah. and
help the Iranian people. Isn't that my position that I articulate
in this? What they have done is so >> No, no, Luna Box
doesn't barely articulate a position at all. He sits there desperately
trying not to offend Ethan Klein for the entire time. Like every
time he goes on there to tap dance like a [__] house,
you know? You actually didn't lay out much of a [__]
opinion at all, Luna Box. You never do on that show.
sold them out. They have just sold them out and it's so obvious.
It's so obvious to anyone
I and >> I think my criticism watching this, which I'm
glad. I'm glad I'm on Kick, okay? It takes days for my [__]
to get anywhere. Unless Substance clipping it and Substance is
not going to clip me being too overt about things, okay? But
I just said the reason Luna Box does that is because he doesn't
want to step on these clients' toes.
Like he's Luna Box is trying not to present anything like too
strong when he goes on that show because he knows Ethan is like
a sensitive baby and he knows if he makes Ethan get upset about
him,
Like if if he says something that Ethan's going to disagree with,
Ethan's probably not letting that go and he's probably going
to have a hard time like navigating that argument because Ethan
is again a sensitive, spineless
That's it's just going to be tough, all right? only [__]
lies. But regardless, anyway, it's not even just about the plan.
It's not even just about the plan. I'm saying Shimsky, I don't
look at that Twitter. I also I assume it's like flagged.
My NSFW stuff's off on stream by default. If you wanted to do
this successfully, right? That's what I'm saying there, right?
I'm not saying this would be justified just with that. Cuz this
is what my concern is. Is that Luna Box's position and this is
this is like the good faith version, the ultra good faith version
of the thing he's going to call bad faith in a bit, okay? At
the end of the segment. And Quin wonders why people won't talk
to him. What do you mean, Drama 101?
I don't think Quin I don't think Quin is confused why being like
caustic makes people not want to talk to him. I think he's of
the opinion that they exist in a space where if there are good
critiques being made, they'll engage anyway, even if somebody's
being an ass about it. Like the entire premise of like all of
Twitch politics around
Was explicitly he was a caustic like unbearable douchebag to
everybody and they still engaged.
Quin probably just wonders why the rules are different here,
right? I'm guessing.
But Drama 101, if you have a different reason why you think people
don't talk to Quin other than their feelings get
love to hear it. I think I'll end the segment. The idea that
if it was Trump and Hex said
Calling Luna Box a house and is good faith. Yes. It's literally
good faith. By definition, yes.
Do you think Quin believes that Luna Box is a house and
I know he does cuz he's referred to him that way in private.
This is not new. This is not a revelation to me. It's definitionally
not bad faith. He's saying what he believes.
If it wasn't Trump and Hex had done it, he would support it.
And my concern, my worry, the thing I'm really condemning for
Luna Box said is the idea that he would support them doing roughly
this as long as it was done well. I wouldn't support that because
I have not exhausted
uh the available internet Which by the I disagree with that characterization.
I don't say that, right? I disagree with private, too.
But I'm not I'm calling that bad faith. You are doing the dog
whistle right now, right? You're calling it bad faith instead
of just saying it's a mean thing to say.
I don't like that you said that. That's really mean is what you
mean to say.
Not bad faith at all. special options. They have nothing from
the Security Council. There's been no like uh statements or something
about the violence on [__] protesters or anything
from the UN Security Council. It hasn't gone to Congress. There's
just not been any efforts justified
And my concern is based on things I've heard Luna Box say and
defend in the past is that he basically just thinks it's fine
to just go around doing these decapitation strikes without really
putting it to the international community. He seems to support
an air strike on Iran. He goes on H3 and says, "No, this is like
failures and it could still be good." Potentially is the the
Ayatollah is gone, but then there's the youth of the IRGC who
are easily the most indoctrinated, most radicalized faction of
the entire Islamic Republic. They're the youngest generation
and they're more radical and more hardline than the first the
first Ayatollah than the second than anything. And that's actually
partly why they managed to it was quite easy for them to crack
down on protesters because these young [clears throat] security
officers are just very, very willing to do whatever it takes
to keep the regime in power. Uh there is a chance that they survive
the air strikes to the degree that they can that they can establish
some kind of military dictatorship. There's a chance that they
survive There's a chance. There's like 100,000 people in the
IRGC.
If he starts talking about the Basij, I think there's still thousands
of people in the Basij.
you can't air strike every civilian Sorry, every military officer
in a country that big. It's too expensive. You can't do it. over
Iran, which is worse than what we currently have, but there's
also it could also go particularly well, right? You could have
defectors from the army
Yeah, this is this is horrible analysis. I'm sorry, it's horrible
analysis.
I and I think this is a
I don't know. I never would have said these things, right? That
there's a chance it could work out. It it can't. It it logistically
cannot.
100,000 plus for the Basij? Oh, a hun- 600,000 reservists? Oh,
so yeah, just no chance at all. To to make this work, to actually
affect regime change, you would have to do boots on the ground.
You have to. You have to. You have to. You have
Good is bad analysis. Now, I think Luna Box would probably just
concede that it's really bad analysis to present those as equal
possibilities. Well, you
you know, one out of one out of a million, one out of a million.
It either happens or it doesn't. We call that a 50/50 chance,
all right? Let's >> Like he was like, "Oh, no, what are
you saying here? How it's going to be worse?" It's like, "It
could also go better. It could also go better." Yeah, there's
like no reason to think that's the case, though. the Basij, like
the security forces, you could have protesters who are able to
>> I do I do wonder actually. Is he trying to say that
the protests were inspired just because of the 12-day war because
that exposed the regime and showed their weakness. Is that what
That's what he said earlier, right? That doesn't even make as
much sense either. No, you're No, I'm obviously I think that
played into it. I think it'd be crazy that it didn't play into
it. But obviously it's not just because of the [__]
12-day war or just because of Trump. But all these things all
these are factors, no? Is that a [__] crazy to say?
I don't I think that's totally reasonable. Obviously, yeah, the
strikes last year
uh was it last year or was it When was it? Do I even know? It
wasn't last year, was it? No, it was earlier this year. Dude,
I'm losing track of time.
Was it last year? 11 months ago. Jesus. 6 months ago? I'm going
to lose track of time, dude. I'm losing track of time. Anyway,
yeah, I I think obviously that played a role. I do think that
played a role. I do think making the regime look
is going to make the the opposition population more likely to
rise up. I don't think that's controversial. I don't think it's
crazy to say.
Uh the economic crisis happening in Iran is largely It's still
They're unarmed. It's an It's a disarmed nation. That's That
has to factor into your analysis. There is no way you actually
weaken this regime enough, right? Unless you had significant
splintering in the regime, but again, there is no indication
whatsoever that these people are not
It is a theocracy. They are They do believe.
There is a lot of sincere belief in the country,
I don't know how to tell people this, but even if it's, you know,
three to one
in terms of people who are down with the regime versus people
who oppose the regime, if the people who are down with the regime
in a country of 90 million people or whatever it is, I think
it's about 90, if three to one you're outnumbered by people with
guns, you're [__] It's over, okay? being attributed
there to the uh snapback sanctions. But the snapback sanctions
were Well, yeah, yeah. And the sanctions have created conditions
that are like unlivable or not like totally unlivable. We are
in like pretty bad conditions for the average person and that
makes them more discontent with the government as well. And there's
a lot of reasons, I'm sure. There's a lot of reasons. There's
a lot of factors here. But I'm making the statement I'm not making
the statement that any of these are determinative.
I am saying that Trump holds responsibility and the US and Israel
and the Shah hold responsibility for egging those protesters
on with the promise of help and not delivering.
That played into them getting killed.
If they had helped, they may not have been killed. Now, even
though I don't know that help at that point would have been justified,
but hey, that >> Oh, yeah, that's another good point. Not
accounting for when Israel decided to bomb all of those tankers
in the middle of Tehran and make it rain oil, probably causing
like 100 different types of cancer for that entire population,
right? Before that, maybe they had a chance. I don't know what
they're doing now. That would have been better.
seemingly going to get imposed one way or the other because they
weren't imposed by um they weren't imposed by America. The snapbacks
came from the European powers cuz the European powers uh France,
Germany, the UK, they were still part of the JCPOA. And when
it became very clear that the IAEA was seeing very, very behavior
from Iran with the 60% nuclear enrichment, when they were when
they were seeing that, they re- they instigated the snapbacks
the snapback sanctions because
they were about to expire anyway. So they but they they stopped
The JCPOA still did exist. It's just America wasn't part of it
anymore. So I don't know if we're going to blame them for it
or we're going to blame our own country and France and Germany
because those were the new sanctions that came in between the
12-day >> Like it's all about blame. Like I I I What is
this [__] [__] saying? Does he think
I'm like
bigging up the Iranian regime? Does he think I'm like pro IRGC
or something? Or what what do you think is going on here? Do
you think I'm saying "Oh, the Iranian people would love the Ayatollah
if it weren't for these Western powers putting sanctions and
making them manipulating them against Islam." You think that's
what I'm saying, Luna Box? You're some kind of [__]
Iran today. Are we going to blame them for destabilizing Iran?
And I don't know if he's suggesting that they should maybe get
involved when the protesters were actually out there in full
and before it had been better if it was possible, but it wasn't
possible. firing happened, but then the issue there is they didn't
have the means. They You know how Trump had to like how America
was deploying all of that [__] over to the Middle
East in the past few weeks before the strike. So you can say
that My position is not that they Drama 101, if you want to come
on the Discord and talk about it, we could totally talk about
it. Seems like you're asking some questions as if you're like
trying to nibble at the edges. I would love for you to just come
on the Discord and say why you think this is wrong or what you
think is going on that's incorrect. should have done it then.
They shouldn't have done it at all. They should have gone through
the proper channels. They should have made attempts to to go
through the UN Security Council. They should have gone through
Congress.
But it would have been better to act
It would have been better. And if you can't act, then don't say
you will. missed opportunity. Like this is I feel like none of
this is remotely controversial, no? Honestly, this stuff is not
even really like it should get back to basically the idea I think
the criticism from Quin should just stick to the same thing.
Why are you on Ethan Klein's show pretending that this is
Pretending that this could possibly work, right? Like that's
that's all this comes down to, right? Why are you on Ethan Klein's
show for this big network opportunity, sort of sort of like giving
credence to the idea that the Iranians might be able to rise
up, that this might work out well, and saying it's like equally
likely to it failing.
That's really where you should really That's Sorry, that's really
where you should center the criticism, not really necessarily
picking at the edges of his commentary here. As annoying as it
is that LonerBox is making it about something else. You can't
stop. If you do not have the military hardware in position to
stop the regime from killing the protesters, then do not make
tweets and speeches where you say
"If you kill the protesters, I'm going to use military hardware
to stop you."
If you can't do that for another month. Like there's so many
aspects here where it's just totally wrong. It's totally wrong.
It's totally morally repugnant. >> What's I What can you
do? What can you do? You're saying they shouldn't do this? Yeah.
Yeah, I am actually. Yeah, that's what I'm saying. I'm saying
they shouldn't do it. But it's quite impressive how much they
could have done to help at that time as well, which is why Trump
tweeting that thing out was so [__] negligent and
so >> Oh, yeah. I I guess he's I guess he's just saying
he's just saying he agrees with me. Yes, it's disgusting. Yes.
>> That's why we should move on. And then saying help is
on the way when it turned out the only help he was referring
to was some people were making something
If it were any
If it were any other This is who when I ask people when I heard
people talking about Reza Pahlavi, I I I kept asking "Which point
me to the that's talking about this. Point me to the that's And
nobody pointed me over here, which is unfortunate. Although I
I truly think that LonerBox is
If I remember correctly, didn't Ethan bring up Pahlavi?
I don't know if LonerBox is like sincerely really believes that,
but then if the criticism would be why are you saying if you
don't believe it. the president I would completely support it
>> Saying Hezbollah is not anti-Semitic. >> But it
is you know, it's the basically same as
You know.
There's a lot of just They're just saying it to mean "You're
It's a way of using a special word
for Jews lying or Muslims lying. You know.
It's It's >> It's hard to It's hard to overestimate just
how bad the current situation is. >> What? So what was
the point of Loner's 50 facts bit when he agreed?
The point of the 50 facts bit is basically that if Queenman was
suggesting something about Iran maybe not being that bad,
uh which is going to be the perception of the audience as Queenman
is saying something along the lines of actually the the Iranian
the Sorry, the Islamic regime the Islamic Republic not that bad
is what the audience is going to think. And so he is JN-soothing
by going "No, Iran really is bad and they they rise up all the
time and they do brutal crackdowns all the time. Iran really
is bad. No, I got it, guys. I know Even though he I don't even
think he really thinks Queenman is saying this. He's saying "No,
no, no, no, guys. You just Ooh. Ooh. Just deep breathing and
I'm going to let him know here's all the bad things Iran has
Iran has done very bad things, sir."
Which by the way, it has. It's just like nobody's really saying
otherwise. It has nothing to do with me complaining about
the people pretending that this could have worked that this after
it was started the way it was that this could have worked. I
I I don't know what what kind of like what this what what ideology
we have going on here. I'm making I want my brain to say thank
you, but like he actually preferred Pahlavi. If you think Pahlavi
would be worse than the current regime, you are [__]
[__] You know nothing. If you think
No, I think we might as well prognosticate about how well Santa
Claus would do running Iran. The Easter Bunny would be fantastic
as the new Ayatollah. Sh- Who cares? Why are we talking about
fantasies that can never take place in the real world?
And the current regime is anything but the same. If you think
the Shah the actual like the big body dictator Shah Right, he's
like bugging out over Goon Squad with the Tom Foolery profile
picture. I feel like this is this comes up this exudes a lack
of confidence. I almost don't care about the political opinions
in my chat
because I know I like you anyway. Either I'm right and everyone's
going to come around to me anyway or you know, I'll I'll just
adjust a little bit for them or I miss, you know. It just I I
doesn't I I like don't give a I could not give a [__]
if some [__] thinks that the Shah would be worse
than the Ayatollah. Like obviously I don't agree with that. I
think the Ayatollah is particularly bad, but I I don't think
>> know why why is he just lying right now? Why is he acting
like he wouldn't tell somebody get in the Discord if they were
saying things in his in his chat? Why is he pretending that?
The Shah is like great. Queenman is really sitting here like
I didn't multiple times just watching this vid alone hear him
go "That's a timeout. You're [__]
Now he said political opinions, but I know he would do that over
political opinions. Get the [__] out of here. >> like
a huge fan of Reza Pahlavi, but there are only good options really.
It's like the Ayatollah or an IGC or or a
Reza Pahlavi or the MEK. You wouldn't even know about this regime.
You you know nothing. You know I'm sorry. You just don't you
don't know anything, okay? The Shah for all his brutality and
killing political opponents and everything the Islamic Republic
outdid him within months. They within months they set up tribunals
for the political opponents and were executing more people within
like a year or two than the Shah had in his entire couple of
decades rule. Like [__] hell. He actually preferred
Pahlavi. You have course don't understand how bad the Ayatollah
is. You don't understand how bad they are. They're like really
bad. They're like
really bad, okay? They're like He's really bad. He's really bad,
okay? Guys, I know. I know. I'm letting him know. Everybody in
the chat I'm letting him know that the Ayatollah is really
He was evil, okay? you [__] idiot.
What is it What is it Was Iran stable when they murdered at least
7,000 of their own people in 3 days? Like no, not really. I mean,
what what is stable
At some point there does kind of need to be a change. So it's
just a very real shame that you've got But he just said What
is it What was Iran stable when they murdered at least 7,000
of their own people in 3 days? Like no, not really. I mean, what
what is stable here? At some point there
Something sh- for Indian Dude, this I think this Queenman guy
might be racist,
Racist and homophobic. >> does kind of need to be a change.
So it's just a very real shame that you've got Trump and Hexaf
leading the charge right now. That's a good point. Yeah. Very
problematic stream. Most cynical.
>> Wait, I have to go back. That's me.
Oh, no. LonerBox misunderstood the English here. I have to go
back now cuz I remember this. >> more people within like
a year or two than the Shah had in his entire couple of decades
rule. Like then he actually preferred Pahlavi. You have course
you [__] idiot. You That's right. PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
OH. OH. OH.
THE chatter actually didn't say that LonerBox preferred Pahlavi.
The chatter was making fun of LonerBox for proffering Pahlavi.
He proffered Pahlavi as a reasonable alternative as somebody
who might happen. He proffered
So LonerBox misread he The word is proffered, but he read it
preferred.
And it's a totally different concept, right? That you you prefer
one candidate over the other versus you're giving one as like
the idea that could happen,
What is it What was Iran stable when they murdered at least 7,000
of their own people in 3 days? Like no, not really. I mean, what
what is stable here? I point that out to LonerBox and I At some
point there does kind of need to be a change. So it's just a
very real shame that you've got Trump and Hexaf See, he LMAO
he actually proffered
Pahlavi. He actually said Pahlavi might be a good Pahlavi might
be a thing that could happen, right? That's what this message
is saying. leading the charge right now. That's a good point.
Yeah. They're kind of the least competent.
>> Most cynical. Is that what LonerBox does this Oh, what
ideology is going on in your chat? What ideology How do you call
these snocky tankies in in your chat? I said you go to you go
to LonerBox's chat or Discord and it's like
Yeah, the thing about Palestinians is they all went to I can't
even say it, bro. Living in bombed out sewage. Living in mud
huts. In bombed out sewage. And they just can't stop [__]
killing It's actually not like that. They're not like supremacists
Israelis. They're like hyper JN Israelis, okay? They're like
They're like constantly talking about what massive victims they
are of everything happening in the world.
And I I just I don't have patience for. It's very frustrating
for me. killing
What does JN mean? Uh Jerroditism. Like being overly neurotic,
thinking things are going badly for you when they're Um having
very little empathy for other people's experiences, putting your
your your experience above theirs consistently, right? Having
like literally zero empathy for people who are facing far harder
circumstances.
toilet. You give them You give them indoor plumbing. Like they
get all up to rockets over the border. Which is I'm a I'm a 101.
Hop in the Discord, man. You seem like you really like to dislike
this Queenman guy. I bet I could get him on to argue with you.
I bet you he's probably out at a club right now or some [__]
in England, okay? 2:00 a.m. He's probably drunk as [__]
I bet you I could get him to call in. Call in, man. Hello. We
just Hello. That's like That's like the LonerBox audience. As
in you could have to do it.
>> Um this is a video by the way of when the news hit Iran
that the Ayatollah was was killed. Just to give you an idea.
>> Yeah, I believe that. I'm driving right now. Uh-huh.
Like you're watching us shilling for the strikes. Also, by the
way, guys, tell me tell me tell me when Destiny goes online so
I can stop watching LonerBox. Someone tell me when one of my
favorite Someone tell me when my favorite streamer goes online
so I can cheer at LonerBox. Say you're just shilling for the
strikes. I'll be real with you Do I say?
Yeah, I will. Okay.
LonerBox's drama channel is just a Destiny fan channel. And people
get upset that I say that because they you know, I'll point that
out to people and they'll go "I dislike you. I I don't even like
Destiny. I dislike you." It's like okay, but if I'm not here,
I'm just reading that chat, you guys are consistently posting
like Destiny tweets, Destiny clips, Destiny stuff in that chat
more than LonerBox stuff,
At least from what I've seen. I'm just That's just facts, okay?
That's just facts. I'm sorry.
That's just the way it is.
Bro, there's nothing worse than when Kolinda Kolinda joined like
the voice channel with LonerBox. It was like "Yeah, I Yeah, I
like kind of like Destiny, but I'll usually watch you if you're
both
Usually I'll watch you."
Is he talking to the Iranians or or to [laughter] Ethan? Like
what should Should people just not show this? Is this just irrelevant
information?
That's like universal rejoicing.
Why are you apologizing to us? I'm apologizing for the clip that
Spider's making right now to post in that Discord right now.
Or Black Cat or some Whenever I like talk [__] about
them, somebody's watching the stream just so they can They're
watching the stream as I like mock their neuroticism constantly.
They're through tears just waiting for the moment where I talk
about Lunar Box or the Discord so they can clip that and post
it in the Discord. It's like literally in tears having to listen
to me mock them. And then
I got you now. You said mean things about me. You said mean things
about the Discord. What the man?
There's like if you were afraid
that there was people that dis- a lot of people that disagreed
with you. Well, no. Obviously, I'm aware. Selling it The US selling
out in certain groups in Uh I I do like Spider like unironically.
He's just like he doesn't get it yet. He'll get it eventually.
But I got I got no real problem with Spider, okay?
Spider's okay in my book. Guys, you know sometimes gifted. Thank
you. Huge appreciate. Thanks so much. Um I'm sorry. In every
country supports stupid people all the time. It doesn't mean
that it was a good idea. It was a good idea. You were afraid
that there was people People in his chat like Destiny so I blame
Lunar.
Yeah, that's what I said. That's uh
You typing very well for a driving. A lot of people that disagreed
with you. Well, no. Obviously, I'm aware. Selling it The US selling
out in certain groups in the Middle East is incredibly common.
I'm aware. I'm aware.
But I Listen.
Actually, no. I I'm done with the talking about it. >> Isn't
just like the group It's It's like the people. It's like 80%
of this population want their government gone. Want the regime
to fall. They had these mass protests. And then tens of thousands
of them were
And you sat there and watched.
You made these gay warnings saying well, if you if you kill these
people, we're going to do so. We'll stop you. Did nothing. Watched
them get slaughtered. And then when the resistance is crushed
then you kill the leader. Then you kill the leader. And people
are defending it.
Is he talking about that they just came in too late? No. It's
part of the argument. But the way it was done is particularly
egregious. No, that's not my problem. It's not It was just too
late. No, there are a million other problems with that with it
before we even get to the too late part. I am describing why
this is particularly
And yeah, Never lays out an opinion. Never lays out a Oh, does
he really think Does he really think Does he really think Say
something, man. Say something. Like he would support it. Dude,
I do think the criticism Oh, these people Huh.
people even read
the entire JCPOA?
Have these people even read the the entire JCPOA?
I I'm sorry. [laughter] So, if he did it during the protest >> even
a thing. I Listen, I've I've only heard Lunar Box do it once
and it's a very common amongst streamers to do, okay? But I I
just have a
dramatic react I have a trauma response to that exact way of
arguing. It's not cool, man. >> Remember In fact, let me
let me throw let me extend an olive branch to all of the people
who are watching this in C thing who are very mad that I'm talking
[__] okay?
I think Hasan does this about as much as anybody if not more,
okay? Hasan is famous for the
I don't even know, man. No, okay. The protests had resumed. So,
if that's the decision the protests had resumed five five days
before the before the strikes. Yeah, how could they have like
40,000 of them killed? Yes. Dude, it's not just about the protests.
It's not just about the protests. Obviously, part of protest
is having organized groups that you have groups organizing those
protests. And a lot of the people that are likely to have died
in that month-long gap in that 40,000 are going to be people
that were attracting the most attention on the front lines of
the protests, I would imagine, if they get gunned down. And they
probably tried to track organizers down, too.
So, it So, the key part of this is not just that there are people
out in the streets. It's that the the organizers, the people
that would be pushing and are making the effort, the the ones
that put their head above the parapet the most have now been
killed.
So, it makes it infinitely harder for a
overthrow attempt.
Students were back out again, but Ethan saying you're like oh,
look how happy the people are. I don't even think me or Ethan
are defending it. Where are we getting this >> Ethan Ethan
is literally the whole way through like oh, well, you know, it's
not that bad, is it? Wow, great. Wow, great. Yeah, it means so
much, man. It means so much when their entire organization has
been But why is Ethan bringing this clip up? Why is Ethan bringing
the clip up? Ask yourself that. Ethan Ethan isn't defending it.
Why is he bringing it up? This is unironically more dishonest
and manipulative than Hasan trying to pretend he didn't shock
his dog. Weaponized incredulity BPD >> even that drama
being brought up. the other side. I just don't want to [__]
hear about Hasan shocking his dog. Thank you for the [__]
Thank you.
That's funny. Uh funny funny super chat. >> You know had
any role in the protest. >> Good times. >> has been
slaughtered in the streets.
Protesters who are able to overwhelm government buildings that
have been or the government positions have been weakened and
you can actually have Hezbollah becoming and his plan working.
It's It's a very If it were any other president, I would completely
support it. Because right. It's It's hard to It's hard to overestimate
just how bad the current state of affairs is, right? People thought
What do you mean if it was any other president, you would support
it? Any other I So, I think it's obvious what I'm saying there,
right? I think what I'm saying is that the overall principle
the overall like uh idea of you give air support to protesters
who were out before the air strikes started, by the way. You
give air support to the protesters who take out the regime. You
take out their ballistic missiles, their nuclear threat, their
um the So, literally with the process followed beforehand, right,
Lunar Box? No, this is again, it's actually
This wouldn't be my criticism. You can't take out this num- this
many people. You can't even Unless you have intelligence of like
significant splinters. Like unless you have some sort of plan
where the CIA and the the Mossad have been here and there's like
two factions that you think you can get to flip on each other
if if um the Ayatollah's gone or something. Like unless you have
something like that going on, you could cause a civil war automatically.
But as soon as they reach out to the Kurds, everybody realizes
oh,
Oh, they didn't plan [__]
You can't air support bomb your way in into having like an unarmed
populace overcome a military like arm that has hundreds of thousands
of people in it. It's just not possible.
It's literally not possible.
You need people who are armed on the That's the other thing is
you probably only get up in this military by being like devout,
right? Like it's it's There's probably a ton of purity testing
that's happening along the way, right?
Hey, this woman just just refused to wear her hijab. Do you want
to break her legs for me? No, I don't want to do that. Well,
do you not believe in like our dictates?
I'm guessing there's tons of [__] like that as you
move up through these ranks.
it's just going to make it so it's a very hard nut to crack in
this way,
With a with like a UN Security Council resolution, preferably.
With like congressional approval, preferably. Right, Lunar Box?
Right?
I just see security forces and then that allows the protesters
to step in the space and reclaim their freedom. Like that's the
whole gist of the idea. And if any other president were going
to make that decision, they would absolutely be weighing up questions
like Lunar says that right now. Kleiman paused at a bad spot.
What he What? Are you like typing to me what's going to happen
in the video while you're
Are you like so invested that you're actually typing in my chat
while you're driving, apparently, which we all know you're not,
but I'm going to keep going with it.
Or are you like looking at his Discord and getting notes from
him right now? Are you telling me what happened in the video?
I don't even know.
What do you mean Lunar Box was saying he Cuz it seemed to It
seems like you're saying that you're talking to Lunar Box right
now. Uh are there enough defectors that we >> So, literally
So, he is espousing It's like unless it changes in the next few
seconds. It seems like he is espousing the position that I'm
saying is disgusting. And he's calling me bad faith for saying
that he's thinking So, you have the position. You have the disgusting
position, which is I would support war crimes if they were done
competently. Just do them well. That's what That's what you're
So, yeah, I'm fine with the illegal strike on this country. Just
do it competently. And you know, obviously, like I've said earlier,
like I laid Which by the way, I would just say means the Venezuelan
boats. Like those boats those drug boats that we're getting shot.
You support that, too, right? I don't know what the differentiation
is. I don't know why there's a differentiation, actually. It's
just might makes right that it's pretty obvious the Venezuela
stuff's all okay. Yeah, yeah. There are edge cases once all other
options have been exhausted and you're in a corner and it is
the humanitarian He did?
Wait, did he Did he support it or he just say it was legal? And
then beyond that cuz oh, did he have There's no way he had the
Avi position. Cuz it was very obvious that Avi was looking for
a way to say that it was all legal and okay and good because
Avi doesn't want international law to apply to America. Cuz if
international law applies to America and people agree that international
law should be applied to America, then that means
that international law should be applied somewhere else, too.
I mean supporting. Like you're saying like this would be something
you support. He's saying ought. This ought
If you're willing to say this ought happen with Iran, then I
don't understand where the ought changes with um the drug runner
boats.
I don't get it.
full out plan things to do to to intervene. There are cases where
something could be illegal and you still take action. Kosovo
obviously being the
But we're not there. We're not there. And you're not laying out
those prerequisites. You're not laying those out in as necessary
for your as for your support. You seem to pretty clearly be saying
no, you're fine with the US head of state basically unilaterally
deciding. Obviously, you know, he thinks there would be more
consultation and weighing the options. But essentially unilaterally
deciding Yeah, we're going to war with Iran. I'm striking Iran
because I think this regime is really
Without consulting you know, the international community without
going through the UN. Which is literally That is the disgusting
position that I'm condemning. So, if that's what you think Yes,
I think that you have a very disgusting position on this. And
you should be treated like an Nazi. You should be like, you know,
like I say, like the German citizen that goes along with it.
Because the US is the Great Satan. And if you're playing defense,
you're you're filth.
Go back with another video to do this. >> I don't think
I would play the video again. Um are the protesters like in a
position where they can actually have some level of coordination?
Is Hezbollah Oh, yeah. I don't think it Dude, they They just
took down like apparently 500 people got de-partnered on Kick
And then I think um Bijan Tehrani, the one of the co-founders
of Kick is also a big not a big fan of the regime, okay?
I I don't think I can risk playing regime propaganda on stream.
>> I think that could go badly for me, >> Pahlavi's
promise of 50,000 defectors is actually even real. >> be
sincere. >> What are the ramifications for the rest of
the Gulf region? What's it going to do with with regards Yeah,
entertaining the Pahlavi thing is just silly. to what happens
to Israel and Hezbollah because obviously the rest of the axis
are going to want to respond in some way. Are they going to respond
in a forceful way or or in a kind of pathetic way is going to
matter. Um there are all these questions that I don't obviously
are they going to justify it to the people or are they going
to go to Congress or are they going to go to the European powers
and explain their plan and everything so that it's got like stages
of approval. But obviously they haven't which means that like
it's hard to tell if this was executed on good grounds or just
on nothing on just Trump seeing a prize. >> the thing,
he's not stating those as pretty firm prerequisites. Obviously
like he's laying out like I have to carry out this every single
time. First of all there is there are carve outs. But he is not
saying that's like a prerequisite. He's saying like that'd be
like a good idea. But based on everything I've heard him say
it does seem like he's fine with like these unilateral decapitation
strikes. guys and just chasing it like a [__] child
like like a fascist murdering child. Like that's that's kind
of what I'm saying. I think that's quite clear.
No, it's not. You just say cuz Lion of the Box all you say is
I would probably be in favor of this if it wasn't Trump and Hex
self doing it. That's actually not very clear, Lion of the Box.
That's actually not very clear. Even here you're not particularly
clear. You're not actually laying out like firm
You're like leaving room.
You're like saying yeah, I know the president would probably
do that. You're not saying I would not support it unless >> No,
he's not a monarchist. Well, I've seen no indication he's a monarchist
or I've seen indication he's against the regime which I think
most dias- like diaspora are. It's just whether or not they support
the monarchy. I don't think it's like a he loves Pahlavi or the
Shah or something. I don't think it's like that. But I don't
know. I haven't seen too many of his tweets.
>> That that's like the firm position that we're looking
for, Lion of the Box. I do not support these attacks because
they are illegal and no not all other options have been explored
and there was no imminent threat. But it's they're very clear.
You can very clearly lay out a firm position. Why do people struggle
with this, man? Yeah, Hotep does too. Why do people struggle
so much with laying out this is what I think. I think this is
wrong because X. I would think it was right if Y.
Can we can we manage that? Can we manage that? Or we'd probably
be in favor of it if it was if it wasn't Trump and Hex self doing
it.
Not very clear, is it really?
Agree in the sense that any other president would not have done
it like this. No other president would have done it this Obviously.
But why are you shouting at me? Not even Bush with a storm, you
know?
I agree in that sense. Mhm. Okay. But the idea that if you take
roughly what has happened here Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I've already I I replayed this when I was first watching it off
stream uh like five times just to make sure I knew what I was
listening to. done it like this. Is that is right? It's It's
hard to It's hard to Yeah, yeah. Why why are you yelling? Uh
cuz I'm projecting my voice and making it bombastic and entertaining
for the audience, Lion of the Box. So rather than sitting there
and going Oh, yeah, it's it's He's actually yelling cuz he doesn't
want his noise gate his noise gate to uh I don't think he he's
I don't think he has a noise gate. But um he doesn't want his
noise gate to cut him off. He doesn't want his mic to go out.
So that's why he's yelling, okay? Be very very aura killing to
lose your
lose your train of thought in the middle, okay? Have it cut out
for because of your noise gate. Again I suppose he's like lefties
need to learn how to read books. I suppose like lefties need
to learn how to read books. Lefties need to learn how to read
books. on my live stream.
probably coming in this plan working. It's it's a very
The thing about comparisons is
people say one thing like another but it's not exactly the same.
It makes me really upset.
If it were any other president I would completely support it
because it's it's hard to it's hard to overestimate just how
bad the current state of affairs is, right? People don't get
what you mean if it was any other president you would support
it.
Here comes the weasel brigade to spam chat with Queenan and Jay
Star cope.
Bro, what? What do you mean cope? They have a disagreement. I
people just
Also why do I even get dragged into
I was I happened to be in a conversation today in Lion of the
Box's Discord that Lion of the Box was a part of. the president
would not have That That was why I am looking at it now. I didn't
care about this before. Come on, man. No other president would
have done it this [__] Not even Bush with a storm,
you know?
I agree in that sense. But the idea that if you take roughly
what has happened People act like this is life or death. Yeah,
it's not that serious, man. It's [__] It's just It's
just content, dog.
Just have a conversation. It's just a collab, man. Somebody disagrees
with you. here. You would support it from a different president.
No, this is disgusting. What do you mean by that? Roughly from
a different president like Yeah, so if you take roughly the actions
occurred here as in a unilateral decapitation strike
that hasn't gone through Congress or the and was not
you know, done in coordination with allies and weeks late
with no on the ground like force ready to take power from the
regime.
Yeah, if you take roughly that and put it on another president,
even if it was done slightly more competently Okay. That would
still be terrible. >> Oh, thank god. For a second For a
second I was like oh god, we're only this far into the video.
I was going to lose it. Holy [__]
Yeah, that that necessary for support.
It sounds like you're suggesting that I would support the exact
same actions with the same level of calculation with the same
consideration of international ramifications just if you put
a D next to it. It Yes, Lion of the Box. When you say I would
support this if it wasn't Trump and Hex self doing it Um dude,
I don't know how to explain this to people. This entertaining
the idea as soon as you put a different president in charge of
this, it becomes very obvious that it won't
Right? There is no set of circumstances you could make happen
here. Like I that yeah, there's just given the facts as they
are. I do not believe there's a set of circumstances where another
American president decides to do these strikes.
They do not benefit the American people. Trump is the only person
who will take his personal benefit and put it above the American
people and that's why he's doing these strikes.
It's just that like that's just the way it is. It's just facts.
I'm sorry. Doesn't matter how many times you say well, Iran's
really bad. They cracked down on protesters. They killed Americans
in like 47 years ago. They killed a bunch of Americans. Doesn't
matter how many times you say this,
No other president would do this. It takes the unique generational
once-in-a-lifetime
that is Donald Trump to go along with this [__] okay?
Well, what you've just said is obviously an extreme hyper-specific
version. Yes, that is roughly what what I'm going to take. Yes,
you would roughly these strikes from a different president you
would I would support it if it was anyone else. Right, yes. I
think roughly the thing that happened here you're saying you
would support done by someone else. Yes. Yes. So it's just like
is is it necessary to Lion of the Box
that all other options have been exhausted? That you've gone
through the UN Security Council? You've hit that road block of
China and Russia veto.
Is going to Congress justified to Congress necessary? Are these
That's the question really being asked of us. Cuz that's totally
different. That's a whole different thing. It's a whole different
thing. It's like a whole different strike.
It's just that American foreign policy tends to just be realist,
right? That's what it is. If you have a if you have a calculation
you can make that this is going to help America, you will do
it. That's how America operates.
This is like the first time in America's history where they're
like actually being puppeted by Israel, okay? This just didn't
make any sense. All right? When I say realism I mean
brutal like harsh pragmatism. I'm going to just do like a calculation
of how much this helps the American bottom
Right? That's it's a like political theory called realism, okay?
And and obviously
what about Vietnam? I assume they think that like making sure
communism isn't infiltrating places was something they they put
at a high
like uh a high premium. America or rich people. America like
um It's mo- It would be mostly about the elites but the American
interest to keep America the global superpower. That's why America
does things, to remain the global superpower. And by the way,
that includes going and doing like horrific crimes, horrific
like like helping, you know, borderline ideological Nazis like
go and kill a whole bunch of good people and take over their
country so that you can get [__] from it. Includes
that, right? Just telling you. That's that's how it is. Mostly
about the Well, unfortunately like that's also the case
is you have a group of all I don't know, shepherd the country
better. Is the way it is.
If it's not unilateral, if it's months of planning and discussion
with the with public and international community
it's not the same thing at that point. You're not supporting
the same thing from a different president at that point. And
then what you said would be wrong. It's not actually what you
think. Yes, that's the lie America says we're just spreading
democracy. BS, they world
Do you think I just said they're spreading democracy? I basically
just said they would cut the throat of like a benevolent um like
a benevolent president who's democratically elected to put a
dictator in place if they could get like uranium or something
from that
So I'm not I'm not saying they're spreading democracy. I'm saying
they're going to do things that make good outcomes for America
happen.
The same behavior with Congress, the same behavior with European
allies. What the [__] man? What is this? What am
I watching? What is this good faith principle critique from our
boy here? What the [__] This is disgusting. Wow,
so responding to him he says I would support this from anyone
else. And I take that to mean so- someone else doing roughly
these actions you would be in favor of.
That's bad faith. That's bad faith, guys.
How could you possibly lie and smear Lion of the Box like that
lay out and smear Lion of the Box like that? How could you possibly
do that?
Taking his words to mean
the exact literal meaning of the
with no real room for other interpretations. Cuz I I don't say
that I would agree with your position that this is He thinks
that I say I would agree with his position that I would support
this from any other president. No, I'm saying I agree it would
have been done better.
But I'm I don't agree that you would support that you should
support roughly these actions from any other president.
And now he's just going to angrily agree with me for five minutes.
Involvement.
Uh there was any
consultation with the international
Uh no. If you would support this action from another president,
you are scum. You are filth. You are just Like yeah, cuz I would
if it were another president, yeah. If Biden just did the exact
same thing but just because it's Biden doing roughly the same
thing. We're saying the same action. That's what you're saying.
What you said in the clip. Maybe you don't think that. Maybe
you don't believe that. You said the same thing. So we're talking
about a unilateral decapitation strike. They decided, America
decided, we want to intervene, we're going to go do it.
Even if it was done well, still bad.
Make me happy. Like do you seriously think that's my position?
Is that what you think of me? What the [__] man?
Yes, that's what I think roughly your position is generally,
yeah. I could be
But based on the other attacks
I mean, I forget when this happened precisely, but I'm pretty
sure Queenan went on to argue that Hassan didn't um
didn't lie about mass or something, didn't he?
Wasn't that Queenan's argument? Went on and argued with Luna
Box about it. I've seen him talk about Might have been Might
have been Noah Samson, actually. to be all he's got. Like he
doesn't really believe in international law. He's like a ends
justify the means on foreign policy. That seems That seems to
be the case. Like some subhuman drone, frankly, to steal a term
from Haz, to steal a term from Chomsky. I have seen this bit.
I have rewatched this bit. He doesn't like this, guys. He doesn't
like this.
Like some liberal fashion drone frankly, to steal a term from
Haz, to steal a term from Chomsky, a liberal fascist. You are
just a degenerate Westoid.
What does this have to do with fascism? Megalomaniac who thinks
you can go around the globe execute Well, so the point that I'm
making is that the idea that you've decided essentially there's
this group like, you know, essentially the whole of the Middle
East that you can subjugate and punish and exploit.
And you don't even have to consult even your own people about
it.
You know, you you you don't unilaterally you do it as a as a
as a, you know, authority figure. My man Queenan back at the
top of his game. Luna brings out your best.
>> That person donated that and then Queenan immediately
went on vacation again. That person is so
Thank you for the huge appreciate. Thank you so much. Meddling
in other people's countries without ever without even consulting
your own people who paid for the He's He's completely riffing
on it now. He's just He's just taking that to be like I said
Yes, that's what I'm riffing. Yes. Yes, it's a livestream. Yes,
I'm riffing. think about how Trump has done this. Just that it's
not that should be what it should be
think that Queenan spent a lot of time studying this segment?
Does he Does he think that? Bro, Luna Box got got more faith
in Queenan's ability to prepare for his streams than his stream
chat does, okay?
Bro, ask ask Queenan chatters how hard he prepares for his stream.
Shows up to stream, guys, just guys, I kind of want to do this.
Just put the links in the channel, okay? Get me the links. Maybe
I'll do this later. a different face. It should just have a D
next to it. That's what he's doing right now. And I know full
[__] well he doesn't believe that. That's why he
started saying, "Oh, yeah, I agree that a different president
the statement. No, I don't think you would support literally
this exact action with a D next to it. I think the way I'm reading
that statement and the way I still kind of read that statement
based on the way you're speaking here is roughly these actions
from a different president, from a Democratic president, you
would support. So it it doesn't matter if they're gone. I don't
think to Luna Box it matters, and I could be wrong like I said.
I don't think it's necessary that they go through the UN first
to Luna Box. I don't think it's necessary that they go to Congress
first. By the way, that I Queenan's reiterating the exact criticism
again about following procedure like for the hundredth time.
Maybe I I could just hit play, but I'm not going to. I I just
want to say I make all those same excuses. So I'm not really
throwing the first stone here. I'm just I'm just laughing. Luna
Box is generally ends justify the means, and if this had been
done in a more competent and planned way with with a day after
plan and everything, he would he would be in favor of it. That's
what I think. That's what That's what I think. To totally
totally clear cuz I get frustrated with Luna Box not laying out
his opinion. That is clear as day my opinion, okay? So if Luna
Box doesn't think that's how he thinks, he can just say I don't
think that. It is absolutely necessary to me that they go through
the international community and Congress. All other options must
be exhausted before you
do something like this. They would have done it differently.
They would have consulted Congress differently. They would have
consulted Congress and they would have informed the European
allies and they would have had a much better grasp of what the
potential outcomes are. And if it So again, he's saying informed
European allies. So I informed European allies. You go through
the UN Security Council and you push it as far as it will go
until you can't push it any further cuz of China and Russia.
That's what you do. You make the argument on the world stage.
You push that forward. You try to pursue the legitimate avenue.
And if it is so, if the the moral crime is so abhorrent
that it must be acted upon even without that authorization, then
at that point you act. You don't just decide you're going to
go do it. You don't decide you're going to do it and inform your
European allies. But no, you go through the UN. Those potential
outcomes were not favorable. If they were actually potentially
way too destructive, he would have maybe even just not done it
at all, which I would also support as a decision. I'd rather
this decision was put in front of of the desk of someone who
can actually make that decision.
Which is why I would also trust a yes from someone like Biden
much more than someone like Trump. So he understands all that,
but he just had to do it this thing that I got I don't [__]
why. Fascist, bro. It's Simon to come come on again over this
and walk back most of his statements.
>> What are the statements that he would walk back?
What do we say, man? What is the argument? What What What is
the argument there? Why is it two way? Why is it two way?
We're so back. We're so back. You know, like Iran antagonizes
countries in the region. They don't just murder people in violation
You know, Iran's really bad, guys. You know, Iran's really bad,
guys. You know, Iran's really bad. That means international law.
Thank you, guys. I mean, Iraq, Lebanon, and Syria. It's also
It's also America. They've They've attacked Americans. Even just
in this in this decade, just in the
Well, Luna Box, maybe leave that one out. Maybe leave that one
out. Not quite as compelling as the last one. A couple of few
years ago there've been Hey, dude, I swear to God the um the
thing that is happening though
is like you would Trust me, if you were Luna Box Imagine that
instead of a chat it was like your your like nagging wife, okay?
And every time you forget to like bring up your wife's concern
in a conversation, she like nags you about it for the next like
3 days in a row just over and over and over again. That's why
Luna Box has to run down the list of all the bad things Iran's
done. Cuz if you forget to talk about how bad Iran is
uh you're going to hear about it, okay? You're going to hear
about it a lot. Iranians attempts to murder journalists who are
from the diaspora who disagree with them, who oppose the regime.
But That's besides the point.
Yes, that's that's my position. Sorry. Such a non sequitur. Guys,
so you But you you think it's wrong to brand any other people's
countries without consulting the international community or going
through the UN Security Council or doing anything? Uh wouldn't
you know that Iran's really bad? Cool, man. Awesome. Wow, high
level stuff. All those books doing you good clearly, Luna Box.
All those books doing you a lot Okay. Yes. And that makes you
and your little [__] gaggle happy. Yes. Every single
This complete up This entire operation is based. If only for
the fact if if only it could be done with Hillary Clinton's head
on the planes. Okay. The Nicholas De Oreo fans. Damn, I I guess
there probably is a lot of Nicholas De Oreo overlap, isn't there?
I didn't think about that. I didn't think about that that much.
Real quick. Just real quick.
What do you think of Nicholas De Oreo? I'm a big fan of Nicholas
De Oreo. What can I say? You do your research.
>> You know what the best part of this is? It's a little
in the middle of it. I'm a big fan of Nicholas De Oreo. What
can I say?
You do your research.
>> She really do be doing that a lot, okay? It's [__]
up. necessarily true. When you If you analyze everything on the
It doesn't have to be worse. It could be. It could be worse in
the sense that one outcome potentially is the the Ayatollah's
gone, but then there's the youth of the IRGC who are easily the
most indoctrinated, most radicalized faction
of the entire Islamic Republic. They're the youngest generation
and they're more radical and more
hardline than I'm sorry, but there's already worse. I don't [laughter]
think it's going to get better. And you're
coping like this. Like you sound like a coping like this.
Even just to me, it's like clear what's happened here.
The US is already The US and Israel already destabilized the
country. I've never seen a good faith clip from this
Bro, what? I How do these people not know what this means? How
are you viewers in like this space you don't know what this means?
I don't know how to tell you this. If I genuinely find
How do I put this? If I call you a That's not bad faith. I'm
just calling you a That's Never seen a sober stream from J's
Dog. You ever had a sober stream,
Dude, it's What? Like I think what they're looking Is it I'm
trying to think of like
It's like the antithesis of a steel man. If you take somebody
super literally and don't try to infer at all what they're saying.
But Queenan does a little bit of inference of what Luna Box is
saying, and it's not really that far off.
entering the regime with the initial strikes on Fordow and all
that [__]
Uh 6 months ago, whatever.
That already weakened the regime.
There's been a swelling of support
for an opposition.
due to American and Israeli interference and incitement. US
state officials, former state officials
are saying say openly Was it Huckabee, I think, or Pompeo? One
of them said openly
good luck to all the Iranian protesters.
I know there are Mossad agents marching alongside them. They
say this openly. They have fomented the resistance, the opposition.
How does that even work? [laughter] So first of all, I don't
know if he's forgotten, but you know, Iran deals with urban uprisings
or protests or whatever like all the time. Like every few years
they're having to go through another round There's no way I went
to a different I went to a different thing. Holy [__]
I was like I was like Dude, I'm starting to get deja vu. I think
I went way back. I clicked on the wrong I This was the previous
one we were looking at. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I I like heard it I'm like immediately
like, wait, what? Why is he saying that? Why is Queenan saying
that again? You're like fine with these unilateral strikes. That
seems to be the case. That's what you're saying.
As long as it's planned well.
But yeah, you think that all the people should be informed, but
ultimately it's just the US president's decision. They just do
it. It should be a Nazi. What? Belongs in a box belongs in the
Tower of London cuz he's a [__] traitor. And Lone
Wolf sees that and feels upset about that. I'm not going to be
like, I'm so confused >> THAT'S SO BAD FAITH THAT you just
said this guy should be imprisoned.
That's so bad faith. What the [__]
says up Wait, wrong vibe? No, this is the right The previous
one was the wrong vibe. This is the right vibe. >> No,
I've just said. Now, Lone Wolf will say this
Lone Wolf about something that ends up being true.
He'll sit there and bemoan and act like the [__]
victim over the fact that lefties are upset with him over it.
And then >> think a single lefty is upset with me over
this. They just see an opportunity. That's all it is. That's
That's all it is. I don't think they're upset by it. Especially
since this clip, I remember it was me just initially saying I'm
going to need more than the word Well, I'm not a lefty and I
do think that like broadly when you try to treat
I think you were doing of Joe said it best. I had like a Joe
clip a while back. How many streams ago was that?
I'll I'll just play the Joe clip. Let me Let me go back to where
I have that. It was like a It was like a Joe clip where she was
talking about how it just feels like you don't really care. If
you're going to present this as like they really do have a chance
and these strikes are going to work and they will rise up. If
you're like propagating that, you actually just kind of don't
give a [__] about the Iranian people. You like don't
give a [__] enough to look into the situation at
all, to look at how unlikely it is that any uprising amongst
them will actually affect things and work out. Right? You just
don't care.
And it just feels like really weird >> you're going to
try to moralize. You're going to try to use the emotional weight
from that argument that like you want these people to be free,
but they don't have a chance. It's like It's like you see somebody
in a cage and you know they can't they can't get out of it. It's
impossible for them to get out of it. You're like, "No, no, no.
Just keep stretching on those Just keep like trying to fight
those bars." You're watching them like crack their fingernails.
They're in immense pain. You're like, "You got it. You got it,
man. Believe in yourself. Believe in yourself. Believe in yourself."
Like you're actually kind of torturing somebody. It's like up.
It's like actually weird what you're doing.
of the I had the the Iranian state, which I maintain which I
still maintain. Of course Literally, does he even listen? Does
this have ears, prior? It's crazy. Yeah, I said I have no problem
saying that, but obviously the way you said it is going to set
people off.
When you see a a girl's school get bombed, you go, "They're [__]
liars." It's going to set people off. And I don't think they
all just see an opportunity. Yes, they are engaging a lot of
time in motivated reason. They already hate you. They already
screwed you, etc. etc. We know they do see it and get mad. I
think they do genuinely see it and get mad at you. I think people
are do genuinely like hate you and get mad at you. see would
be more than their word. Like cuz they do lie. They lie quite
habitually, actually. Um but
this whole clip actually even includes me getting more information
like within what? Like a like minutes? Whatever. When Hassan
does this exact same thing to Israel, he'll spend a week talking
about it. What Give me one example you've an emaciated little
like Give me one example. I'm sorry, what? An example of Hassan
getting a breaking >> See, now you're getting it. Now you're
Now he's getting it. Now he's thinking with portals. Let's go.
He is an emaciated little
Yeah. Great tragedy. And then breaking him over the coals because
he says I need more information cuz I don't trust this initial
source. Like what if it's like um like I don't I should be Yeah,
we should be clear. That was bad faith to call him an emaciated
little [__] That was really bad faith. Consider actually
Israel being equivalent to the [__] Iranian state.
>> Exactly. So, there we go. Dude, he literally can't even
do the cope. He can't even do the cope cuz I know I I can't go
and find the clip. I I won't even know what to search. But I
know I know he's made almost word for word this exact point,
okay? Let me try and formulate it. Let me try and formulate it.
Cuz I've heard this so many times. It's what How's it How does
the argument go?
It's some [__] about like Israel being like a a relatively
trustworthy, you know, accountable Western, you know, like liberal
army type of whatever the [__] I say about it. Accountable?
I I don't Does anybody with like an IQ above 65
believe that Israel's an accountable ally? Accountable? And that
if you just That's like the last word. I feel like that is the
lowest That's the least
correlated word with Israelia with with Israel, okay?
It It need Referring to the IDF or Israel as liars is anti-Semitic.
I'm almost certain. I'm almost certain. And
maybe maybe we do something. Maybe I do like I I will I will
bet Lone Wolf. I'll bet Lone Wolf and then we'll get someone
to come sketch so to get a comb for his parts and see if they
can find it. If they I don't know why I started saying Israeli
and then I tried to break it >> Don't find it. Rashed.
But I'm pretty certain Lone Wolf has made that argument. I am
like pretty certain he's done that. I I would, you
I would be pretty confident on that. Cuz I have heard that argument
so many times hearing people talk about Hassan.
And I don't listen to that many people talk about it. for a lot
of reasons. It's harder to suppress information within Israel
than it is in Iran. Um but even if you just say you need more
information or like I don't trust these lying [__]
whatever. I could be wrong. I could be I could be wrong. It could
be that he's never made that argument. It could be Lone Wolf
literally has never made that argument. And I'll say, "Sorry,
Lone Wolf. That's totally untrue. I have an untrue interpretation
of you." But I I do believe he has made arguments along those
lines. I I do believe that pretty firmly.
Same clip shows you like 30 seconds later he's got more information
and he's adjusting his perspective. Yeah, I would rake him over
the coals for that. Give me one example, bro. [__]
hell. It's incoherent. It's inco- I'd bet like 25 quid, you know.
It's a respectable but small bet, you know. Enough enough money
for it to be real money, but not anything that's going to cause
me problems, you know. Here it. It's like the most [__]
entitled behavior from these [__] losers, the zogged-out
Ethan Klein dick-riding who have the most [__] attitudes
in the world. This is the thing, man. It's like it's totally
reasonable to make the statement, "I don't trust the state media
of the theocratic dictatorship." But these [__] out
the moment you see this article, makes you look up and then human.
And you must recognize that cuz you would recognize it in anyone
else. Um and that's why you're going to get flagged for this.
I just I just don't I don't know about people. Like when do I
When have I popped off at someone for getting a breaking news
statement that gets reported? >> pretend to accurately
He keeps saying that it's we're getting a breaking news statement
and not immediately believing it. That's not what you're being
criticized for, Helen Wolf. That's not anyone's issue with. Obviously,
the way you reacted to
I I feel like what they're actually mad about is you saying it
didn't happen when you first read about it. I don't believe these
lying [__] And it's like when it's an atrocity, you
kind of just let it go. I saw that, too. I was like, "Dude, you
should You shouldn't say that." People can get real mad about
that.
Right? That's like the classic Bosch moment. And maybe you don't
blow up on people when they recover 30 seconds later, but that
doesn't always get clipped, right? Okay? I'm just saying. I'm
just saying. >> Dude, it's the They're [__]
liars and not like looking into it, right? It's like If you're
going to I need to look into it, but if you're going to do that,
you need to It's like People want to see you immediately ready
to find the truth. That's what they want. You can handle the
liars if you're ready to immediately jump into finding the truth.
Otherwise, if you want to avoid people getting mad, it's best
to just go, "Oh, I want another source corroborating that first."
as opposed to doing, "They're [__]
Because you can imagine Israel says there's 40 beheaded babies.
Hassan goes, "They're [__] liars. I don't believe
that. They're [__] liars."
And you might be like, "Whoa, Hassan. I mean, that was untrue.
The 40 beheaded babies thing It was actually like What was it?
40 children died. One was beheaded or whatever. I can't remember.
I can't remember the the actual story of the banging that. But
you get the point anyway. I don't know how much of that was Israel
lying and how much of that was Biden
brain deterioration. Ethan took it as fact and went after Hassan
for not agreeing. Maybe that's what my brain is like pulling
up in the back of my head. There were actually two minors killed
in that kibbutz, says Ryan Beard. I don't know I don't know how
true that is. I don't know the truth of any of this stuff. I
don't believe in that attack. But yeah, I think that might be
what my brain is pulling up. It's from all that time ago.
I feel like I must have seen Lone Wolf cover that. Someone find
that. There's got to be Lone Wolf coverage
Ethan going off to Hassan for not believing that. Right? I feel
like if I would have heard him say it, it would be there. an
authoritarian state media and not trusting it until they see
more information. When have I ever attacked someone for that
particular
Wow, yeah, Lone Wolf. That's what I was saying in that clip is
that you've attacked Hassan for literally the exact specific
thing that happened in your exact case.
Not the general same thing. You know, the the reaction calling
the other sides, you know, media a liar over some tragedy and
speaking out on stream.
Like I'm the bad faith one, guys. I'm the bad faith cuz I say
liberal fascist mean words while I'm talking about them. When
these are the arguments. This is the engagement. The third time
something about me. Oh, well.
the Middle East I Yeah, I I think I just would have
probably not said that. I I would have just said it I feel like
people are going to get mad at you for that. Like immediately
when an atrocity happens or it's reported to have happened, you
got to go, "I don't believe these [__] I don't believe
these lying fuckers." That's just not a good look. That's all.
>> Africa. He can't get me off his mind. Okay. Uh regardless,
like if if that happened in North Korea, right? If it was like
you it was getting reported that a North Korean school got bombed,
I'd still be like, "Oh, you probably shouldn't just go, 'Oh,
that that didn't happen. These people are liars. These people
are just total liars.'"
You probably should chill for a second.
I mean, for your own We'll fight about the Hutch thing later.
Stop Personally, I love people denying atrocities, okay? Denying
atrocities is awesome. I'm sorry. My chat's Stop it. More than
[__] Talk about interesting [__] first.
God damn it. Is it your turn to talk about Queen and Jessica
Klein? It's my chat. It's because you want me to fight you about
Hutchison, but I wanted to get through the Epstein stuff first.
Okay, I did not expect Queen to Dude, this guy literally just
totally right. I don't talk about this guy. I do not call the
Destiny.
When was the last time I called the Destiny in any serious capacity?
I barely even retweeted about him.
Let alone make actual comments myself. It's like so crazy.
dominate the stream that much. Okay.
anyways, um I've known Keffals to be an arms dealer. He deals
in the Middle East and North Africa. Just to be clear, I that
statement that I did earlier today. I just wanted to show you
guys kind of why I'm a little bit disconnected from that group
now. Like I just I don't think there's anything valuable going
on Wow. I think I spent a bit too long thinking that there was
some kind of good faith critique or whatever that I could uh
get something from or but no. Just sounds So, that's another
another community. 109 online communities Lone Wolf has been
has fallen out with through no fault of his Through no fault
of his own. YET ANOTHER DOOR CLOSED. WHOA.
109 That is an anti-Semitic dog whistle. Oh, boy.
General racism, homophobia, now
disgusting anti-Semitism
from this Queen parse. This is very
109 boy oh boy >> Yeah, I know they're not closed. Yeah,
another friendship group lost. Yeah, another group on the internet
that [__] hates him. Like I I don't even hate him.
I don't know why I'm saying that, but do you know what I mean?
It's like bro, get a [__] grip. Not everyone can
be bad faith, okay? I understand that the only person who's not
bad faith is Destiny. I get it, man. I see. Destiny and Pisco
and Hutch are the only people in the world who aren't bad faith.
Those are the only people you have a conversation with. Okay,
I see. No problem, man. No problem. Like what else am I supposed
to take from this? These [__]
I don't even want to say it. Or just want to talk to each other.
They just don't want to circle jerk with the same other three
liberal fascists that that agree with them. You know, they they
they just want that endlessly. Everyone outside of that is bad
faith. Every conservative is bad faith. Every lefty is bad faith.
And every anti-Israel lib is bad faith. Actually. Every everyone
who isn't
I think like
there's a different thing going on here. It seems to me there's
a different thing going on here.
I think when Queenman acts like this, when he does this,
I think this is rough because
if if LonerBox was just like Queenman's really rude, I don't
want to talk to him, I would have no real criticism.
But he says to you you're like bad faith, you're not making bad
faith you're you're not making good faith criticisms, which is
just wrong.
He is making good faith criticisms with a lot of like um hyperbole
and attacks thrown in, okay?
What's actually happening in my opinion is that if you talk to
Queenman and he doesn't like you, he's going to embarrass you
not on the substance. He's going to embarrass you by trashing
you in the conversation like he did to Well, he embarrassed Briana
Wu on the substance as well. But when he has a debate with somebody
he really dislikes, he's going to demean them and degrade them.
And if you don't want to engage in that same way, you're going
to look bad on that front no matter what.
So people avoid talking to him. They don't want to be like talked
to like that, so they avoid talking to him, right? Said LonerBox
makes little signals to the Destiny smears.
Um when did he do that? I feel like he doesn't give credence
to the doxing thing. I think, but I'm not totally sure. I don't
really Like I said, I don't really have any problems with LonerBox
specifically. I think
I think he underestimates how toxic uh like a How do I put it?
Having like
certain people in his community I just feel like his I I just
don't get it. That's my thing. I just couldn't imagine keeping
people around who are like
Destiny is like we need to be trum- I couldn't have any of those
people in my space. I'd actually just be like you you need to
go. I don't even It's not even on a like uh basis of I dislike
How would I put it? It's not even on the basis of like those
people are terrible.
It's like I just couldn't be around it. I just couldn't be around
it at all. Like I actually I just hear those people talk and
I'm like
immediately
murderous thoughts in my head, okay?
Immediately. And I just don't understand Yeah, I don't get it.
I don't know how to I don't know how else to say it. I
I mean, I guess it's probably something like this.
It's probably something like
Where could his allies possibly be? It's lonely to be on the
internet by yourself. To have like nobody who talks to you, who
likes you, hangs out with you. It is lonely. And a lot of the
other people in his like adjacent spaces, like the Hasan people
are never going to come around on LonerBox.
So that sort of leaves him with a certain set of allies he could
keep.
And I do see why not punching at those people even if some of
them he doesn't like, I do see why he why that happens.
I do
I do get why that happens. Like it is a job, it is something
you're trying to make work. Yeah. I don't know. I'm like trying
to think it it makes like some sense
to me. It's it's quite difficult to
Like I'm just And by the way, that's not saying he likes that
he obviously doesn't like Destiny. I'm not making that implication.
I'm saying it's why he probably doesn't filter out a lot of the
people who do like Destiny. It's cuz it's like well, he has a
lot of overlap with them.
He probably just doesn't want to ask people to choose. Doesn't
want to make people choose or whatever.
I don't know.
It's rough. I I I feel lucky in that I basically
the opposite. I was like actually actually just go. Go. All of
you can go. Every single one of you guys who wants to like kind
of straddle the line, I would prefer you just go. Please don't.
Please don't come around. We're good without you. I just don't
want I don't want anything
Dude, if I if I lived in a world where like one of my friends
came on were like, you should just like
Aren't you psyched for like collabing with Destiny? I I watch
Destiny's stream like a lot.
But when you're online, like I I sometimes pick you.
I I would shoot myself in the head if that ever happened to me.
I'd actually it would be over, right?
Like I just the fact that I could have somebody feel comfortable
to say that on my stream I'd shoot myself in the [__]
head.
So again, I just don't I don't know. And Israel thing writing.
copyright false copyright strike
malicious copyright lawsuit doxing supporting
lover. Everyone else who isn't that is bad faith. If you don't
If you're not down with and you're down with Israel
and you're down with
I see differentiating?
If you're not down with Israel, is all you need to
>> But whatever else they're down with, right? Whatever
else they're down with. Then you're bad Just say if you're not
down with Israel, that's all you got to say, bro.
It's like I'm sorry, bro. Like total wank. Uh But that's okay.
They can do what they do. Hope it makes them happy.
Very weird differentiation there. >> doesn't try to be
anti-Semitic for the entire segment. [__] this [__]
window, hey.
Cuz this is what makes me happy. Is if I can get this window
to go back into the sub windows. Why is it not doing that? Why
have they
What the [__]
There we go. Okay. There. All right. He's a part of the Iran-Contra
affair where Reagan and Oliver North take weapons, they sanction
bust, they sell weapons for they travel to Israel because you
can't fly directly to Well, here's the reason why they say they
don't have a conversation with him is bad faith is because they're
like Well, you're just going to you're just going to lie to try
and win and how can you ever do that? How can you Why would you
ever do that? You're in a losing position. I'm I'm being honest.
And I can't I can't win being honest if you're willing to just
lie or not engage properly, you know? If you're going to Like
some uh you know, total queer loser [__] reprobate
subhuman like Nick DiOrio might have a conversation where he
sits there and goes, "Oh my god, you just really think You really
think You really think Oh my god, you really think Dude, this
looks so bad." the whole time. You might not want to talk to
someone who's doing that cuz it's [__] sufferable.
And it's just like
designed to make you look bad and then look good. So you might
Queenman would 100% take that conversation and just call him
a [__] loser, by the way. He's saying that like oh,
you might not want to take that conversation. He would still
take that conversation and just call him a [__] loser
every time he did that. Not want to talk to someone who's going
to do that because I can just frame you that way to an audience.
And you just lose. You just get However, you should be able to
at least point out why it's bad faith. Explain how it's bad faith.
How am I being bad faith when I interpret a statement that the
statement I would support this from anyone else as you saying
roughly these actions from a different person you would be in
favor of? You have to explain how that's a bad faith interpretation.
You can't just go bad faith bad faith bad faith at everything.
You have to explain why.
It's not bad faith. It's like the
you're not applying like charity to him.
Like you're not going Well, I respect So this is what This puts
people off. And again, it's just it's like um It's all just how
nice you are. What people want is for you to go, "Well, I think
this person's pretty smart. I don't think they'd say something
completely ri- So if I were like to like think of what would
make me say that. Well, this is sort of like what I would think
a smart person would mean if they were saying that.
And Queenman doesn't always do that, but he I think he did it
in the clip a little bit, right? He does say, "Well, it might
be that he's thinking this."
But Queenman's probably annoyed that this is happening in a like
a collaboration with somebody who's got not a very savvy audience.
And so they probably don't even know the difference. They they
probably just are like, "Oh yeah, well if Biden were It's just
bad cuz Trump bad." Right? That's probably That's probably
Queenman's like actually upset about if you were to try to articulate
it there. Is it it would have something to do with the fact that
LonerBox is not speaking to a savvy audience.
with Iran. Um and Jeffrey Epstein facilitates this with Adnan
Khashoggi and they sell the weapons to Iran. They take the cash,
they put it in a black ops slush fund. Well, the unfortunate
thing here is my wand is that
basically like all of LonerBox's viewers and fans think Queenman
is like Satan.
I don't know Do you What do you think Do you think I'm
Do you think I'm the big Satan, he's little Satan, or vice versa?
I think
I have to be the big Satan, right? He's little Satan. Just thematically.
Right? I'm not totally sure which way it goes, okay? I'm not
totally sure which way it goes, but
think they think Queenman is worse?
Um it depends on who they listen to. It depends on like where
they get their opinions from. Cuz if they listen to Destiny,
they would think I'm worse. But if they listen to like other
people, they could easily think Queenman's worse, right? So it
just depends on where they get their opinions from. Oh yeah,
if they're DiOrio fans, they might think Queenman is worse, for
sure. If they're if they're DiOrio fans, they might think Queenman
is worse. That's definitely true. Yeah, is that what they think
of you, Johnny Bravo? I don't think so.
for me
I will never be as like intelligent and and effective as a lot
of DGGers seem to think I am. Apparently I'm like organizing
a bunch of, you know, doxing behind the scenes.
I just play Civ, bro. I just I'm sitting here trying to suze
up like three different city-states right now, okay? That's what
I'm doing most of the time. Anyway. So
What was I about to say? Not big Satan little Satan Oh, right
right right right right. So what I was going to say here, I was
responding to a comment then I got totally distracted. So it's
mostly that the information LonerBox is going to see is going
to be curated entirely with like only bad things that have been
said about him.
That's all he's ever going to get to see is just really bad things
being said about him by me or Queen and or chat
Right? That's all he gets to see. That's all people are going
to show him. So, unless he wants to take the time to like watch
and try to look for for other moments, he's never going to find
those other moments. So, as far as he can tell, like we're super
hateful, super evil towards him, right? Wish you What do you
think I'm not being neutral on here, Velvet Moss? I think on
the political take part, I if anything I was kind. On the bad
faith stuff, I'm just on Queen inside. Cuz what Lonerbox should
be saying is, "You're mean. I don't want to talk to you because
you're mean." Right? That's That's what the actual criticism
is. "You're mean. I don't want to talk to you cuz you're really
mean."
that then runs uh guns and drugs in Central and South America
for counter uh communist operations in Central and South America.
Okay. Okay. Then, Jeffrey Epstein um well, that that's actually
really important, but I want to add something as well about Adnan
Khashoggi. He also facilitated deals and there's a picture of
him facilitating arms deals in Western South Africa as well via
something called the Safari Club, which was a financial and arms
trafficking Hold on. What am I looking for? Some people in Loner's
audience think Wait. I'm going to find this thing that
Porter Bella was responding to.
I want to see Some people in Loner's audience think Queen is
lying about So, there's possibly some people who would argue
he is the big Satan.
Wait, is he Oh, right. He's Dude, he has to be little Satan,
okay? It's over. It's over. I get to I get to claim pig. I'm
America. and export Free booting Destiny. So, there's all these
guys that watch their favorite streamer. Very nice. Very nice.
I guess he stopped talking about me there, though. So, wow. What's
it Let's see this clip. Let's see this clip. Let's watch this
clip for like a retweet. You can tell me if you think this guy
is like um
good faith critic or not, but We've seen this clip. We've seen
this clip already, okay? So, anyway, that was all of the stuff.
I don't think Lonerbox responded to this at all, right?
I don't think Lonerbox responded to it at all. And actually,
yeah, it works better this way and always, in fact. So, Lonerbox
didn't respond to this. Okay, so now we have the the tweets from
today. Holy That gets us to
the Missy Elliott tweet from today, okay? Where she basically
says, "Oh, here's spiders." Spiders sort of like I I genuinely
again, I'll reintroduce this just in case people are coming in
I and that spider was like copy pasting Queen's criticism intentionally
to with
I mean, this is my criticism, too, but I just assumed spider
got it from Queen cuz Lonerbox specifically responded and said
it was bad faith. And then, spider basically took the same criticism
and asked again.
So, I was just I thought spider was around. And then,
so after this, Missy basically says one of Lonerbox's important
community members has questions to Queen but
similar questions to Queen's positions on Iran or about Lonerbox's
positions on Iran. Jesus. Reading is hard.
Red Logic offers to moderate a conversation. Seems like a great
opportunity to clarify. Make it happen,
means the chat clip about him wanting to
have the zog off.
But, for some reason, uh well, again, we We're pretty sure this
is because Substance retweeted the Missy tweet, okay?
Hassan comes in and says, "They're gaining sentience. I welcome
development. I'm being totally sincere. This is healthy intellectual
curiosity."
Uh suddenly, Hassan appears in a Missy Elliott thread. Awesome.
You love to see it. Oh, right right right right. Yeah, Lonerbox
quote tweeted Hassan's
post activity or somebody did. Dude.
Uh what the
Shut the up, servile regime puppet.
What the Oh, spider deleted.
Wait, somebody get me the tweets.
Somebody's got the tweet somewhere. Somebody archived that tweet.
What did spider What did spider tweet? Someone's got it somewhere.
Lonerbox replied.
Box Loner. The regime needs to go, but the way Trump A all are
making it hap trying to make it happen is insane and immoral.
Not that complicated. It would have been much better if the protesters
had succeeded in January, right, Hassan?
Did Hassan respond? Not seeing Hassan respond. Hey, what I don't
want to see here is people saying insane things.
Why are you so hesitant to push back on Ethan, though? Ethan
brings up a clip of Iranians celebrating Khamenei's death to
imply that if this is good for Iran, and you just sit there.
Sure. I think that's like a complex thing to push back
I don't really want to I just didn't want Lonerbox to say, "Well,
actually, it's 50/50." That's
like oh, this might be good, this might be bad. It's hard to
say. Like no, it's not really 50/50. It's not hard to say. It's
not even like a little bit close. It's just really bad that this
is happening and it has no chance of
Oh, spider deleted this. I mean, I think questioning any US military
operation is pretty normal. If people are curious about my position
or trying to understand it better, that's generally a good thing.
So, yeah, if that's what you mean by healthy intellectual curiosity,
I guess I'll take it. Thanks.
Didn't Wait, didn't spider also push Lonerbox again? Didn't he
also like quote tweet Lonerbox or something? Feel like spider
also quote tweeted Lonerbox, no? Hold on. Where'd Lonerbox post
at? Yeah. Feel like spider was asking another Honestly, I'm not
sure the the protesters succeeding would have changed things
that much. If something like 30,000 protesters were killed and
the regime still didn't fall, that already shows how entrenched
it is. And if it somehow got to 100k and people still couldn't
change anything, then at some point, it's like, well,
we've also seen cases like Hong Kong protests where huge numbers
of people mobilized and it didn't end up changing the system.
So, protests alone don't always lead to regime change. I don't
take it with the IRGC in power. But if protests can't realistically
bring change, then the outcome might just be the regime moderating
a bit and dialing things down, like reducing uranium enrichment.
Wow, like they offered to do.
Like they offered to do. Like they off Like they were totally
offering to do.
What? Ethan explicitly said on the show that it was nearly universally
supported. Uh that's Yeah, that's That was my main criticism
throughout the entire segment watching with Lonerbox. I'm like,
dude, Ethan's saying things. And you're not really correcting
him. It's like so soft or not at all.
It's rough.
Queen responded to the spider tweet. Uh-oh. How are you lapping,
Loner?
>> The protesters had succeeded is the assumption that
the Oh.
The protest led to a fundamental change in governance.
Don't be ogre boy. Okay.